Three,
two,
one.
Oh,
away from.
Don't know why your brother.
What's going on?
Good to see you again,
man.
Hell yeah.
You're on a wild.
A magical mystery tour of the United
States of America here.
It's been amazing with your kids.
You cute little kids.
Door doors,
damaged door,
not your own.
Dick Meyer.
Adorable.
I love kids.
But you,
uh,
you're taking them to.
You took everybody like you.
You're here for how many months?
Five months.
You moving tired of Australia?
Just the big trip.
No,
it's better over here.
It is.
I love America.
I can't say that.
They won't let you back in.
Yeah,
probably not.
They're very different.
But the American landscape,
how unique the landscape is.
The rocky mountains to the desert.
It's just.
Yeah,
hate.
Everyone really thinks Australia is just
like these fucking flat pays the sand.
Mountain ranges and shit.
Really?
How tall they get 'em out and either
high,
but they're up there like a real
mountain.
Rocky Mountain.
Lack of real mountain.
Like Rocky Mountain.
Yeah.
Really?
Wow.
Dude.
Let me tell you something.
Your 28 days that you did in the rocky
mountains out here that we put on
Instagram,
you know that we're promoting it
constantly.
That was one of the most talked about
like every I got calls from all my
friend Bert Kreischer was fucking
obsessed with you.
He wouldn't stop calling me about it.
He's like the fucking goes by himself to
do the video with him,
with the grizzly bear and he's pointing
the gun at it.
Jesus Christ,
can we.
This thing is it's.
That's normal shit.
It is.
That's very normal society so removed
from it now.
Well,
if you're out there,
it's normal to get false charged by a
grizzly bear isn't living with 90.
Yeah.
One good reason.
Not fucking be out.
I was talking with Kim about this when
we hiked into the back of Montana to the
spot that's usually got a bunch of
grizzly bears that I go to and we'll
talk about you.
How you won't come out to Australia
hunting.
He just scared of everything.
The difference is when you're walking
around the mountains here,
it can happen at any point because
fucking grizzly bears,
they got feet,
they walk on land.
In Australia,
you pretty much have to go into the
water,
so you're only worried about that.
When you go to click water or you're
thinking about having a washer or
something.
Here,
it's full time.
For whatever reason,
it doesn't bother me as much to get
killed and eaten by a bear.
Does giant saltwater crocodile.
I reckon the crocodile would be nicer,
but yeah,
it'd be nicer.
Like grab you drag it down.
You'd drowned anyway,
you know,
and then it would do what it wants to
go.
A grizzly bear is going to fuck a mole
year.
Scratch your face off.
Bite your neck,
take chunks out here.
It's going to be longer,
dude.
Yeah,
but it's American.
We're want no foreign shit.
Fucking know.
Florida is eating to this summer about a
grizzly bears.
It's most terrifying things that they
just eat you.
They don't kill you first.
He just holds you down eating you.
Yeah.
They treat you the same way.
They treat a salmon.
You know,
when you see them hold on salmon and
they take big bites out,
they don't make sure they killed
thought behind it,
you know,
like,
I'll finish it off first.
And then did you say the mountain lion
that I ended up hunting?
Yes.
Yeah,
he did.
Yeah.
And like mountain lions usually kill
their prey,
but obviously grabbed the cough and
eliminating this cough
was still alive like a beef cow calf.
Yeah.
I saw the video pretty disturbing.
And then
I seen him on not long ago.
Someone shared with me with a mountain
lion dragon,
a mule deer down.
It's like chomping on this mule deer
before it actually dies,
you know?
And it's like there's just not that
thought process there.
There's not that human.
No,
as long as they make sure that they have
it as a meal,
it's not going anywhere.
They're just getting done with
some friends were elk hunting and they
came across as elk who,
uh,
these wolves had torn the back legs
apart and were,
uh,
it was in the river and the wolves were
eating it while it was in the river.
And the thing was moaning and screaming
and couldn't go anywhere but bull elk in
the,
in the water and they just pretty,
pretty horrible for us.
But I don't give a fuck.
That's standard for them.
So have you encountered any bulls when
you're out there?
Yeah,
plenty of times.
Jay.
The first time I went to Canada was
northwest territories and there was a
pack of wolves that chase chasing a
Caribou bull and they pretty much chased
this thing to like a lever of sweat,
you know,
like this is the winter.
So the bull Caribou bull got really hot
and like chased it,
ended up freezing cold river and I sorta
surrounded in the river and then I just
left it and I walked off,
you know.
And it wasn't that they'll walk away
from their killed.
I knew the job was done,
the wolves went back up high and they
get onto these rocky benches and sat in
the sun and we'll log drawn out their
souls and cooling down and drawing out
these Caribou never left the river.
It was just quivering in the river.
And then that afternoon when we come
back that Caribou is just a caucus.
We've like flesh hanging off the ribs on
the side of the river.
So they come back down once the river
had done his job and
wow,
smart as hell I.
that's,
that's really crazy that,
that intelligent that they know.
It's over.
Like,
oh,
okay.
He's in the water in the water can chill
now.
Dry Off.
Yeah.
That has been crazy.
I are so wise.
People that I know that I've seen them
in the forest say they look at you a
different way.
They look at you,
there's a way they look through you.
They look at you in a way like almost
like they think that that's the reason
why the myth of the Werewolf exists.
Is it people that have these terrifying
encounters with wolves,
they swear it's part human because you
make a's and into looking into you.
They're figuring you out.
You know,
you got to think what it would be like
if you're just out there.
You know,
if you're lucky,
live
five years old,
right?
You get this hard scrabble life out
there chasing much larger animals than
you and you've got to kill them with
your face.
Yeah.
Crazy.
I had a pack of like 30 wolves this last
trip that I was in BC and I kept coming
around camp.
We had horses in that,
in camp and um,
one day I ventured out to try and get
onto them and get a better look at them
and like just without seeing me,
they just kept these perfect range,
you know,
like that hail back to me.
I was trying to call him and all is hell
and that back to me and I just hate
these perfect range and you could tell
the whole time now communicating because
then there'd be a novel Wolf for a
couple of wolves that were like a couple
of miles in the other direction and you
could hear them moving the same patent
that the rest of these walls were.
And I got eyes on him from a distance.
I walked across the Nice Lake.
And other than that,
I never really seen him.
But I guarantee you those wolves looked
at and they have a bunch of times,
like they're just a different haunted
dude.
They'd probably just trying to figure
out what they can do with you.
Yeah,
such an eerie feeling too.
So it's like snow and it's like why in
the back country of British Columbia and
like I'm going up on these mountains.
It's like big pine trees and everything
like that in every direction around you,
hal.
And you'd hear them how and you'd hear
him do it.
Sounds like a Bach.
It's not as likely the short hair.
And then every now and then you'd hear
one hail different and you could tell
that that was the alpha.
This the sound that it was lit now,
dude,
earring or some place to be.
If you're in the night,
she'll a crazy place to be if you're not
in an internet chef.
Fucking like,
yeah.
Well the thing about them that's so
fascinating about them is they're
cooperative and they almost are.
They know what to do without,
without even communicating.
They know what to do.
They have plans and strategies.
He know how to,
how to box someone in circle around like
if an animal's running in a certain
direction,
they get out in front of it.
They know what to do.
You know what to do.
Yeah.
So they end up being a set of Caribou
tracks that I ended up getting onto and
following and every wolf track was a
certain section of pot from that and
I'll funnel it into these big drainage.
I had to end up returning back to camp
because it was getting dark,
but I would've loved to have kept
following insane if I actually like
their efficient good chance.
I ended up catching that Caribou,
you know,
and killing it.
Yeah.
Well it's really interesting seeing them
adapt to a once in 1994 when they get
reintroduced to yellowstone,
seeing them readapt to the whole west
and really expand and dominic and we
were talking recently about Wyoming.
There was this one surplus kill.
These wolves had run across a bunch of
cows,
milk cows and they killed like 18 of
them just killed him.
Just slaughter and yeah,
they just,
they got,
they caught him.
I think in high snow and they couldn't
get away and so these wolves,
just one after
another,
just killed them all and didn't even eat
them.
They just practice.
I think it's good practice and also
think,
well,
it's snowy out.
They probably figured,
look,
we'll come back to this.
We'll leave it in a pile of official.
Yeah.
It's that whole nothing ever goes to
waste.
I suppose.
If they don't eat it,
then grizzly eats it.
If the grizzly donate it birds already.
Something neat it.
Yeah.
That's a fact.
An animal like mean.
Even if a hunter hits an animal,
it doesn't recover it,
that it's not going to waste.
Everything goes back to the values
before you know the world's ultimate
Predator though.
Like everything's fuel in the world,
you know,
the growth on the earth.
Yeah.
It really is a,
it's just a fascinating cycle when you
were out there and you realize that it
doesn't care about four g or cities or
code J.
Four J.
Shit.
I remember when four g was good.
Three G,
three g lte.
Yeah,
that's the one.
It's a good one.
Yeah.
When you're out there in the woods and
you're doing these live streams or
these,
um,
uh,
instagram stories,
how are you,
how are you hooking up when you're out?
Some of them aside.
So some of them are like,
I think the last year on I did the Solo
Ad Hawk for the Arnhem Land,
locked the northern territory of
Australia.
That was like a 13 day.
The lag I think where every dial is
still documenting it,
but it wasn't until that I got back into
civilization that I was uploading the
day each day.
So when you do it on your phone,
it just saves it on the phone.
I'm just filming it in the normal camera
mode and then uploading it.
But a lot of places,
especially here in the US when you're up
high,
like usually I've got half decent
reception.
I'll do a little bit of research,
what's the best provider in their area,
Ita,
verizon,
whatever it is,
and I'll end up getting a sim card for
that provider.
And then usually if I'm not part,
it's not too bad,
but just depends on your legs back
concrete basically.
Nothing could all northern territory of
Australia like Arnhem land,
like nothing at all.
What about satellite?
You can't upload data really well from
satellite.
Yeah.
That's the issue.
And if you could,
you'd want to be freaking rich because
it would charge you a nominal leg.
Yeah,
I saw these things at Rei.
You put them on your backpack.
It's like an extender and somehow or
another extends your cell phone rings.
I used to use them back in the olden
days.
They legit,
uh,
the ones in Australia where they'll
three g like Telstra,
three j that's provided back home now
we're pretty good.
We could have like a big antenna and
hanging off your back and I'm not that
into.
It wasn't that bad.
It was like the size of this cave man.
It was pretty small.
It was just clip on and I don't remember
exactly the mechanism behind it.
That'd be handy if I'm just trying to
communicate with home.
I've got like a Garmin inreach sorta
thing.
And you can do,
you do texts off your phone because it
like actually goes into your fine.
But as far as data goes,
it's too slow to do something like insta
stories.
Right,
right.
Well,
one day,
wasn't it Mark Zuckerberg?
Wasn't he trying to like put satellites
in space to make Internet for the whole
world?
Yeah,
it feels like we need it.
They stopped doing that once Congress
started going.
I know,
I know for sure.
One of them,
they had an a.
One of the tests are rockets that went
up,
that exploded.
I remember one real.
It didn't make it or something like
that.
Yeah,
it's basic and they had stuff in that
one I believe.
I don't think that's ruined it,
but it probably put a big halt on it.
That makes sense.
I always think how you can be so much
unorganized.
Now,
look,
we've worked and stuff because of where
phones nutter,
but I remember like in the construction
industry that morning that you left the
work,
you had to be highly frigging organized
because it wasn't a.
You had to go back to a payphone if you
wanted to call someone.
No one wanted to do that.
Especially from a work site that I'm
now.
It's just the whole,
I just remember when emails come and
fine and I was like,
Holy Shit,
I can save some time now.
Like that was a massive break for,
for business,
being able to do that and then.
But it's also nice to step away from
that every now and then like some hunts
I'm really looking forward to going to
because there isn't any reception,
you know,
and you get away from emails,
business work,
phone calls,
all the shit.
It's just you and nature,
you know.
It's sort of Nice to be like that.
What Steven Life.
I think we're all spending too much time
on our phones.
Too much time being connected in.
Two of my friends are,
you should fear and Bert Kreischer hired
companies to take over their social
media.
Yeah,
they don't.
They don't look at their social media at
all.
What they do is they'll post something
by sending it to them.
Like say if he has a tour coming up,
like,
hey,
you know,
I'm going to be in Sacramento and Blah
Blah Blah.
He sends it to them.
They take that,
they put it up.
He doesn't see it at all.
He doesn't,
doesn't pay attention to a second of it.
That sort of stands?
No,
I'm thinking it does.
You know,
I've been better at it over the last
like couple months than I ever had
before.
But just leaving the phone alone and not
touching it and just hanging out.
Yeah,
I'll do certain posts where I don't even
look back on it.
Just like posted it,
the content out there.
People want to look at it,
they can look at it if they don't want
to look at it,
change the channel gun,
look at something different.
But then every now and then there's one
that I liked to look at the engagement
with and stuff like that,
which is good.
But you know,
there's always like there's 10 percent
fuckwits out there that are kind of.
It's true.
There's like 10 percent.
So I've been looking at
how many followers you got,
like how many people would tune into an
instagram posts of yours each day?
I don't know,
just a guess.
I have couple of hundred thousand at
least I have five point $5 million
instagram followers.
So say one percent of them wakes up on
the wrong side of the just one percent
wakes up on the wrong side of the bed
and wants to be fucking mail fee that
that's a lot of people.
And then your
post is the first post doc.
You'll see again,
I get some shit there and you know,
we're all ignorant if we think that
everyone's just going to get along.
Like that's never gonna fucking happen
is it?
And it's never happened.
But I feel like it's getting worse,
really beer because there's,
you can't punch someone in the face
anymore.
Like it's true if someone gets mouthy,
especially in Australia was only going
back so many years ago.
If someone gets mouthy,
you confront them and if they want to go
at it,
it's going to all get in trouble.
If I do that,
now you know your,
the one that gets in trouble,
even though there'll be an a smarter now
you're the one that gets in trouble.
So you can't do that.
And people know that.
So they get mafia.
There's no repercussions for calling
someone a fucking cunt on
instagram.
That's true.
Like I'm not in favor of people running
around punching people,
but I am.
I do like the way it turns out,
other people realize.
Imagine like when you were in school and
say you don't get along with someone and
they get mouthy and then you have a fire
usually ended up friends after it.
A lot of times,
a lot of the times you ended up friends
over all mass beef he bought a lot of
the times.
It was just sorted out then and it was
done,
you know?
And then other people knew not to talk
shit.
Yeah.
Well it's a weird thing like when you
see UFC fights with guys fucking hate
each other and they beat the shit out of
her hugging and.
Yeah.
I know it's a weird thing with men,
like sometimes you just need to get it
out of your system.
Yeah,
I think it's fucking,
it's primal.
It's human nature that it's definitely
too easy to be shitty to people.
It's too easy and people do.
It's also so new.
The other thing is so new.
I mean any kind of internet interaction
is only 20 years old.
That's it,
basically 24 years I think.
I think I was online in 94 and it was
like a 56 k modem.
It was slow as shit.
My be 56 K,
it might've been 14 four and it was a
way you would use it through the phone
line and go
hit highs,
but we photos great back then were like,
this is amazing.
We thought it was the most incredible
thing.
I remember I showed up to news radio one
day,
the Sitcom that I was on and I couldn't
wait to tell these people about how I
got online last night and I was
downloading all these things and
printing them,
printing up a,
uh,
it was all about Ufo was.
I was really into Ufo Ufos back then.
And I was a reading all these files
about UFO shows,
like government reports about Ufos.
I somehow or another found some,
I don't know what the fuck it was,
a message board or something that you
and I was so obsessed.
I was telling them that was such a big
deal.
It takes so long to download one piece
of paper,
like one piece of paper that was filled
with text would take like 30 seconds to
download.
Yeah,
crazy.
It's crazy.
And now we're here and I'm lucky I've
got three g,
four boss.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Fuck
yeah,
I know you're mad.
It's like,
this is so slow.
Well,
what's a,
you know,
I was telling your kids about the
virtual reality setup that we have back
there.
That disturbs me.
It did.
Doesn't disturb me that you know,
it's bad for you or anything like that.
It's so fun and it's so immersive and I
know and I know where it's going.
I'm like,
it's going to keep getting better and
better.
Just like it was 30 seconds to download
a just a simple piece of paper filled
with text,
you know,
20 years ago,
20 years from now that is going to look
like crayons,
so I'll totally.
But that is the.
You got to put that thing on your own to
freak out.
There's some archery games to there.
A bunch of.
It's pretty cool.
You actually have a.
it's called haptic feedback.
So as you draw the bow back,
you actually feel like a vibration
handling.
Yup.
And then you let go like that.
Tesla suit Jesus Christ.
Tesla.
It's not the same company.
They're just calling it that.
Oh fuck you.
Other company.
Tesla suit on field and ces 2019 takes
virtual reality to new heights.
Yeah.
They're going to have haptic feedback
suits.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
there's like 68 sensors in there and you
can supposedly feel like up to a grain,
I guess,
and put one rarely
cracks.
It wasn't going to put it right on their
posts and they're just going to keep
shooting themselves.
You could have come home,
you'll your girls going to have a haptic
feedback suit on and one of them
artificial machine guns.
It's gonna wreck reality video of a girl
doing it
that she gets shocked.
No,
but this was a couple of different
things.
This is just a test,
but she takes like a hard front kick to
the chest here.
Yeah,
I mean I don't know how,
how it felt to her,
but.
Okay.
Let's see.
Hard front kick to the chest.
Hot Explosion back here.
Actually I did it early.
Okay.
Oh she did.
Oh,
it's not that hard.
It's not your kid,
but I did feel it right here.
Hot Explosion.
Oh,
do I really want to try?
Yes I do.
What does a boxing game that you can
play?
It's really cool.
And uh,
the boxing game,
you see this guy in front of you,
like a big three d cartoon really?
But really cool graphics and when he
punches you the whole screen goes
bright.
Like you got your Bell Rung.
It makes you nervous.
Like when I'm,
when I'm sparring with him and he,
he punches me.
I'm like,
oh Jesus,
got to get my hands up.
And you get exhausted because you're
moving around.
You punching just it's harder.
Believe it or not to punch air then is
the punch something?
Oh definitely.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because you get tired,
you get tired easier.
So you throw in your hands at this thing
and you know you're.
And then she goes down.
You're like,
oh.
And it gets back up at your feet.
Hurt from moving around,
squeaking on the floor and really
interesting.
Yeah.
So there's for sure going to be a weird
world for our kids when they get to be,
you know,
our age.
The world is going to be unrecognizable.
Yeah.
I feel like it's taken the edge off
things to it has it.
It really takes the edge off things like
you haven't actually done that.
Like you haven't actually climbed
Everest,
but I sort of have.
I did it in a virtual reality game and
not really.
He didn't have.
Your life wasn't at stake.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
I've been actually talking about this on
stage that I'm worried about this.
I'm worried about people being able to
have experiences that they didn't earn.
You know,
like if,
if someone,
if,
if there's a virtual reality game where
you play it and all of a sudden you're
in a,
a nascar and you're,
you know,
you're winning some gigantic race,
you're in the driver's seat and you're
shifting the gears and you mean feels
like you're like indiscernible from
feeling like you're winning a race
that's going to happen.
You're going to,
they're going to be able to do all these
different things and it's gonna.
It's gonna make people more and more
dependent on technology and weaker and
weaker and weaker and weaker.
That's how I feel too.
Yeah.
It's like,
um,
it's like going to the gym and working
out and getting all of these muscles,
but then moving away from any manual
labor.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
And not.
I'm not saying don't be fit,
but I'm saying if you'll build them,
muscles fucking use them.
That is true.
There's a lot of guys that go to the gym
and they'll work out hard for 45 minutes
an hour to Jim,
but make them work.
A construction site carrying lumber all
day,
dig.
That'd be fucking complainant for
protein shakes.
And
the real problem is going to be sex.
Yeah,
that's a real problem.
You're gonna be able to put those things
on and have sex with anybody you want.
Like anybody Scarlett Johannsen.
It's fucking weed started.
They're already doing these things where
they face swap with computers,
so they take beautiful actresses and
they put their face on porn stars bodies
and it's hard to tell man.
I mean it looks like a sex tape with a
famous actress that's painted is
disturbing on the Joe Rogan one.
Sure.
There is.
So there is now we mentioned that
talking about it and it's probably the
best thing that's ever lived,
but I think the real worry is that not
just like see it,
but do it like the to be able to like
the matrix going to be able to put this
on and you're going to be able to like
this haptic feedback suit.
That's just one step.
Eventually they're going to figure out a
way to make your body feel it and then
you're gonna you're gonna be able to
have sex with people.
Don.
Yeah,
like anybody you want.
You're never going to have to be nice to
people again because everybody's going
to fuck you.
That's one of the.
One of my,
my point was Kinda onstage is that like
one of the reasons why it's hard,
like it's hard to have sex with people,
like you have to plan it out.
I mean it's not that hard,
but it's,
you know,
you have to agree
that you like each other,
you know,
you have to hope that she likes you and
you like her or whatever,
and there's,
you develop your personality,
like to get people to like you more that
way.
It's more likely be a nicer person.
You get rewarded for that.
You realize,
oh,
it's nice to be a nice person and then
it actually makes you a nicer person if
you don't have to do that in the future.
We're going to be able to dress in a
certain why and Toronto,
Cape Hygienic and us.
And then everyone just turns into a
fucking slaw because they're going to
sleep with some pretty actress.
Yeah.
And in that virtual reality,
they're going to look like Ryan Reynolds
anyway.
You're going to have a full six pack and
look beautiful and then other people are
going to meet you in there.
They're also going to be pretending
you're going to have some disgusting
human beings and then in that world
they're going to be perfect,
but innovative people like me that
unlocked.
Now I'm traditional sleep,
real,
real.
My wife,
real humans is.
That's going to be old school that's
going to be like riding a bike.
What are you?
He walk everywhere.
It's crazy.
The ideas.
I posted a photo,
a video actually,
which is like 700 images stacked
together at at Joshua tree.
I saw that.
Yeah,
and it's like the Milky White crews and
pos,
but then there's just the air traffic
duties in sign.
It's just like constant,
like anyone look at in this muscle
already look like the future,
you know,
look so futuristic already.
And I'm like,
well,
it sort of is maybe this like we're
living in now.
Here it is of the air traffic at about
this point here.
Look at them all just back and forth.
And that's all air traffic.
None of that is asteroids.
Every bit of that to air traffic.
Wow.
That's such an amazing management.
It wasn't until the cameras stopped
early hours in the morning.
That day is for anybody.
This is Adam.green tree on instagram.
And you still have your photography
page,
first man image yet both Mandy image,
first.man image.
And these are some amazing photos.
Yeah.
So that's about 300 photos stack
together.
So you actually get a star trial that's
in Australia.
So that's the southern style,
you know that middle point.
So that's like the south.
And then if you go back to a,
if you go back to Adam dog,
greentree Jamie,
that one
if you go back to like
that style on that's the north style.
So that was pretty cool.
So one's taken from Australia where you
got the southern style,
which is like the turning point and then
this is from America,
like Joshua Tree there,
California and that's like the northern
star.
I think Joshua trees closed down right
now because of the people liked it.
The federal shutdown affect you at all.
I'm like,
no,
I didn't even know about it until you
mentioned it just then.
Yeah,
it's a.
it's going to be awhile to really.
Yeah,
they didn't,
they shut down Joshua Tree because
people were shutting their,
were chopping trees down.
It wasn't just because of the trash
that's it started because the trash and
then over the last week people were
actually going in and like chopping some
trees down like super assholes.
So they was signed.
They will have signs up that it was
closed and I wasn't actually canteen
Joshua tree itself.
I was like out of the tourist section
just off the side of the road where I
could,
but some,
almost signing about,
um,
you know,
that the government or whatever,
the federal government,
you know,
we've all the trash,
but the federal government's not leaving
the fucking trash day.
That's people signature trees are among
the shutdown.
Wow.
There's only a few trees in Joshua tree
and these people were chopping them down
just to be dicks because they know
there's no one there.
They probably turned it from A.
There's just probably trying to be
assholes.
God Damn it.
And that,
that has failed.
Joshua tree is a massive place.
Two,
it says there,
it's larger than Rhode Island.
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
Once you get out of there,
that's a real shine.
This is the thing about people that
don't spend much time in the wilderness
and don't appreciate the wilderness.
They don't.
They just,
well,
they're not connected to it.
They don't understand.
So I had a bunch of people in the city
because I spent the last five,
six days here in La and the bad wave has
come in.
They're like,
Oh,
this is disgusting,
whatever,
and I'm like,
fuck no,
the Bush is loving this.
The herbs,
loving this.
You'd need rain,
especially after all these horrible
fires that you had.
Like Ryan's a good thing.
They just so complaining out here.
Literally 10 days a year,
10 days a year as normal.
Yeah.
I mean it might be exaggerating,
I might be exaggerating,
but slightly slightly like I wouldn't.
I don't imagine it rains more than 50
days a year out here.
That's.
No,
that's not exaggerating and it's 10.
It's probably about right.
Since I've lived here,
might be a little more of the drought
time,
but let's take a guess.
How many days a year on average does it
written in la?
I'm going to say 25,
25 days a year.
16.
I bet you're right.
That's two per month.
That's a lot.
Yeah,
but sometimes there's a bunch together.
Like this is like seven already so far
in the last week and a half.
Let's bet on it.
I'll bet you that Kanye idol.
No fucking way,
Bro.
Shout out to
shout out to plastic,
so that's cool.
For this dope ass Kanye West.
Dol says rain days is 35.
Damn.
Thirty five.
You'll close her.
You can keep this.
It's tough to get.
I should have luck and greedy for sunny
days per year.
Just means.
Yeah.
I don't know.
30 nine inches per year.
It's tough to figure that out.
Thirty nine inches per year is not a lot
though,
so that.
But the.
The problem is California,
right?
It's like northern California fucking
rains every day.
I'll give you go like near the redwood
before us.
That's a.
that's a rainforest.
Yeah.
It was raining constantly.
We spent some time up in medicine.
No,
it's beautiful for the ocean.
Fucking trees are so big.
They're stupid.
Doesn't even trees as big as this room.
Yeah.
You're standing there going,
how old is this?
Oh,
this is a 2000 year old tree.
You're in a desert stretch.
A thousand year old tree is like a
normal tree up there.
I've noticed around the city there's a
lot of Australian natives like gum trees
and eucalyptus and stuff like that.
Yeah.
They must have been important at some
point and just realize I do well in the
harsh conditions.
Well,
you know,
the palm trees is sort of the Hollywood
signature trivia shifts from Hawaii,
but I look good but it's just so funny
that like,
that sort of indicative of what
California is like.
We don't,
we don't have a real,
you know,
just the diversity.
I mean everything comes from somewhere
else here.
There's no like native Los Angeles
people.
You meet one of those and you're like,
Whoa,
you're a test tube baby?
Or say away from rock.
Rocking Disneyland do
is goofy.
Yeah.
What's it like wandering around there?
That's hectic.
So especially like because everything
got to do is like wilderness and out.
Like I adapt.
Fine,
like that's not an issue,
but I don't like it just because I
adapt.
It doesn't mean I like it,
but I'm days needs a different place.
Like I went in there yesterday like
fucking dressed as a man,
you know,
jeans on a flannelette shirt,
Kemo cap and walking around and then the
kids talked me into going to that.
What's the splash mountain mountain.
And my eldest is like sitting in the
front,
that is the place you want to get so wet
in the front.
And I'm like okay,
cool.
And I jumped in the front.
We come down and I'm like,
I'm fucking yelling.
So my mouth is,
I've been doing,
I know he fucking drowned that module at
all.
I'm like,
fuck,
I've got aids.
Vishal.
So a whole Gollup went in the mail,
fucking so drench me.
And then it was called dude come of the
club.
So I've walked around Disney for the
bone and thinking like,
look at these fucking fruit loops in the
way they're dressed in all the Disney
close 90 clothes you can buy in.
There's fucking Disney clothes.
I'm wearing Pajama pants with fucking
mickey mouse's head all over this
fucking this shirt that's got Disney
fucking written all over it.
Fucking walking around there like I
fitted perfectly in after that and it's
like fucking actually look like fucking
who's the owner of Disney?
Walt Disney had fucking shot.
He's load or load
mickey mouse and she load me while we
were there the other day.
They have a warming stations set up
outside of a splash mountain where you
can step into this like it looks like a
phone booth and you get warmed up,
but it costs money.
Everything costs money and Disney.
I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
you can't get people wet to dry off.
Crazy and
yeah,
I think it's all fucking beautiful skin.
It is,
but let me tell you
100 percent.
My kids went mental on those roads.
Have you been to Florida yet?
Yeah,
six years ago I went to Florida.
Yet when you go to Florida again,
you got to go to Disney world.
Disney world.
The world is way better than I think
we ended up going there.
Say it's way better because Disneyland
is pretty amazing,
but Disney world has the best ride of
all time.
They have this Avatar ride.
What is it called?
Flight to flight to pass,
right,
and you ride one of them avatar dragons.
It's all virtual reality.
You put these goggles on you,
you climb on this thing that looks like
a motorcycle and it's traps you in place
and what you're writing is one of them.
Giant dragons.
It's fucking incredible.
Dude is the best ride of all types and a
bunch of friends there and I get text
messages back from like,
holy fucking shit.
I'm like,
yeah,
Joe,
you feel the breeze.
You smell things there.
You see these animals,
you're flying over.
It's wild.
It's all hd.
Three dimensional.
Amazing.
God.
Damn,
it's good.
And now let's take the hunting and
at the end of the day,
Steve Rinella said it best.
This is a.
This is a quote that he said that I
think he was talking about.
Someone else told him this,
that there's two different kinds of fun.
This fun that you have while it's
happening,
like your ride the rollercoaster.
It's fun,
but you don't look back on that five
years from now and go,
that was amazing,
but then there's things that suck while
you're doing them.
Like your 28 day trip in the rocky
mountains pointing a gun that you don't
even know has a jammed bulleted and
grizzlies charging at you like that will
be fun for the rest of your lot.
Toggle.
Yeah.
You'll feel that when you bring it back,
when you talk about it,
there's like cello fun.
Oh,
it's some things that just shallow,
but they cool to do.
There's nothing wrong with doing them,
but they just did not.
Real meaningful example and then this
shit that you do,
this is really meaningful.
You know,
it builds character.
It's something that you'll always look
back on memories and shit,
but this feelings that you get when you
come back to when you appreciate things
like a Calvin and I did this trip with
Rinella in.
I'm a Prince of Wales and we were up
there for.
We were supposed to be up there I think
for seven days,
but on the six day a storm was coming in
and so we wound up bailing early because
I had a Gig in two days and otherwise I
would've been stuck up.
They're like,
you get stuck.
It rained every fucking day and it
didn't just rain every day.
It rained all day.
Every day.
There was no,
there was like,
if you had a break,
it was a five minute break,
like with the,
Oh look,
the sun.
And then just real misery.
So inside the,
um,
the tent,
I put my headlamp on and there was it.
See this is what fucks you up.
You said you think,
well,
when I'm inside the 10 I'll be dry.
No,
no,
there's no dry because the Arabs went,
eh.
When I turned my head lamp on,
I realized the entire inside of the tent
was moisture particles floating around
the air.
And I was like,
fuck me,
I'm in this wet down bag and I'm looking
around.
I'm like,
you never going to get dry bro,
but you know,
you accept it.
But then when we came home after the six
days and I took a shower and then I was,
we were in the car and it was sunny out
and I was like,
God,
this is the best I've ever felt.
I'm so happy.
I don't think you get that happy unless
you feel.
Yeah.
So you know,
the misery and then so,
you know,
the little things that we take for
granted in life.
Every dialogue.
Fucking wow.
Yeah.
Kim Did this hike in Montana with man.
It's just like,
it's like 14 malls and it's just like
not a flat bit of ground on it.
It's just continually going up and it's
in the snow and she,
she had an issue with the leg and uh,
anyway,
we got up at the top and we set up camp
and she's been miserable.
But even a fire there,
you know,
luckily we lit the fire and she's
fucking smile and she's loving it,
you know?
And then we come back to the trial.
I like,
we're not even in the house.
He was just traveling around in like a
winnebago tribe.
And we get back to the trailer and you
get to flick a lot on and turn the tap
on and it's hot water and she's just
like,
fuck it,
I'm going to wake up by.
And then you start taking that sheet for
granted again.
Some people do anyway,
but you certainly can.
But I think a got,
like you,
you're in the wilderness so often that
it's almost like you have a permanent
appreciation from.
Oh totally.
Yeah.
I actually miss it.
I actually don't like this started life
as much as that sort of life.
I see it,
I get it.
I like both.
Obviously I'd need.
I mean I make a living in cities.
Yeah.
Oh for sure.
That's what I do.
But.
But it's nice to go out and dabble in it
and come back out of it 100 percent.
Love it.
Those,
the,
the few hunting trips that I get to do a
year when I'm out in the actual
wilderness wilderness,
like we're in the mountains of Utah elk
hunting.
I was like sitting down sometimes just
sit,
just sit down and take it all in for a
couple of minutes.
I mean,
even though you're in the middle of it
and you're running around looking for
elk and you hear him,
I just like quiet.
Oh,
it's the best.
You thought you thought.
Knowing Yourself,
knowing the wilderness in the real
world,
you know,
it's like.
Because you always say,
I see you said on one of the podcasts,
I don't know if it was one with me or
someone else that it's so funny that we
say the outdoors because everything's
outdoors.
Like fucking everything's under the
ceiling of the,
you know,
that's what it really is,
but it's so weird that you don't really
know the outdoors and unless you stay
out in the wilderness or something like
that.
Yeah.
Unless you're.
And I think also being out there at
night,
at night by the campfire and you hear
things like,
what was that?
Yeah.
He just seems.
And the campfire somehow or another
seems to be able to protect you.
Most animals don't want to fuck with
campfires.
Yeah.
May I took,
came in,
the kids we traveled around Australia
are in,
it must've been the end of 2007 and
early last year and we camped out on the
desert,
which is like one of the last places to
really be discovered and explored in
Australia.
Like there's,
there's no artificial lights out there
at all whatsoever.
And we camped out on the desert.
90 thing that was around us was like
dingoes and camels,
like you'd hear them moving for the.
Not Camels.
Yeah.
But we sat there at camp.
I just had the,
my,
my truck,
my ute,
you know,
with the camper on the back,
like rule lightweight,
set up and we sat there no lights on in
the camper or anything.
So you see it in the pitch black
moonless not.
And the media's dude like I when we
counted 40,
50 media's over like half hour an hour.
Just say an imperfect dude sitting there
with the family and I'm like,
this is,
this is the best.
Like this is.
It was so amazing just to sit there,
especially with the kids and Kim as
well.
Nerving,
when you find out how many times they
enter the atmosphere.
Oh yeah,
there's a,
I think Jamie could probably look this
up,
but I think a hundred tons of media hits
the Earth every single day.
One hundred tons,
dude.
But most of it enters in dusk for
because it breaks up.
But uh,
so last year,
um,
all this up at my cabin just chilling
out by myself.
Woke up in the morning,
they to do a piece,
walked out and I'm looking up and this
media come through and it was so bright
that it actually lead up the ground
dude,
like the most incredible media that I've
seen.
I had a time lapse photo going in the
opposite direction.
I quickly turned that around and you say
that the media is dust it last for 25
minutes,
half an hour in the,
into the camera and it's just drift and
change in shape in the atmosphere.
It was in sign.
So it's just like every now and then is
like a real good one.
So then I started looking it up and I
seen one that rick,
a whole village like in Germany or
something like that.
This asteroid comes through rec and
sheet that it didn't even touched,
but that comes so close to it.
It blows the walls and the windows out
and everything.
And I'm like,
this is fucking scary.
We live on a little speck that's turning
in one of many galaxy.
You know,
my friend Randall Carlson put it best.
He said we live in the middle of a
shooting gallery,
isn't in science.
It's just the time,
the perspective of,
you know,
hundreds of millions of years.
It doesn't seem to.
It doesn't register to us because we're
only around for a hundred years.
Yeah.
So when we look up and we see the moon,
I mean the moon looks like a fucking
stop sign in the most.
Janky is redneck town.
When people shoot it signs,
it looks like it's just fucking shot.
It's just getting nailed.
All,
especially with no atmosphere.
All those things make it all the way
through.
Nothing gets slowed down by the air or
burns up in the atmosphere.
Isn't that crazy how everything just
slams into it.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Magic being up there.
It must be all day long.
I must be slamming things.
It was only,
I think it was like 10,000 years ago.
There was like a big bang,
like,
like a big media hit hit the earth.
And I started looking into that and then
I started really looking into average in
Australia,
indigenous,
how long they've been around for and
stuff like that.
And there's now evidence decided that
they'd been around for 70,000 years.
They live through like three of those
big media is hitting the earth,
you know,
like,
it's crazy to think about like,
why do I wish we had video cameras back
in,
you know,
and I could have recorded that.
We could look at it now like imagine
that.
Well Randall
crossing the guy that I talked about
earlier,
he is a proponent of this theory that
this is what ended the ice age and he's
got some pretty compelling evidence to
back it up in terms of um,
like massive,
massive fields filled with dead woolly
mammoths and died almost instantly.
Some of them with their legs broken from
the force of the impact on.
Yeah,
he's,
you know,
it's really interesting because he's a
guy who,
I don't think he has a degree in this
stuff,
but he's so well read in it that he has
these debates and conversations with
people that do have these degrees in it
and he can tell them things about it and
it's hard in those fields to be taken
seriously if you don't have a phd in
whatever discipline it is.
But man,
his uh,
his work on these things is so
compelling and the podcast that I've did
with them or just mind blowing,
but in,
in terms of like the evidence that
points to some event that ended the ice
age very rapidly and caused the
disintegration of the pole of the,
the ice that was over North America.
North America had something like a mile
high plus sheet device over the of it
just 10,000 years ago.
Twelve thousand years old,
I think.
I was driving through Wyoming and
they've got all these signs up in
Wyoming that a really interesting and it
was desert rock formation.
It'll tell you how all of that rock
formation is,
how it formed,
you know,
because like,
rock usually embeds in layers like this.
It's formed in layers like this and then
you'll see a rock like that,
you know,
all the lines of like this,
that some of them there that are like
hundreds of million years old,
you know,
and there's a song on and it's just,
it's incredible to think how much
they've changed and you just said it
were around for a hundred years of a ton
Max,
you know,
and it's just like we're dropping the
freaking ocean.
Like even the whole human race is a drop
in the ocean compared to what,
how old the earth is.
And it's just crazy to think of like
it's hard to comprehend that they was at
my choice over here because there's not
now,
you know,
but it's been that long,
nuts.
Yeah.
It's mind boggling to think of.
Well,
they,
they find shells in Montana.
I found some on top of Friggen.
Some big mice are out in the desert
dude.
Like there's no water for miles and
there's shells.
There's,
it was like starfish fossilized in the
rocks and it's all like Carl bed,
you know,
and that was like,
that was like the bottom of the ocean.
That was a reef bed.
Yeah.
As the great western inland.
They had sharks out there I think.
I think they had mega dawns in Montana.
Shit,
they find dinosaurs there all the time.
One a Dudley's friends.
Well Dudley knows a guy who has a ranch
out there in Montana and he found a bone
in his,
uh,
in his ranch,
just maybe something protruding from the
ground and he wanted someone to get a
look at it.
So he got ahold to some,
I guess what would you have
paleontologist?
So they went and they said,
you gotta fucking t here,
Bro.
I'll only rex on your property.
Unbelievable.
They,
I think they gave him a million dollars
for it really,
because is a fully intact or close to
intact t-rex.
Far Out.
Yeah.
They apparently Montera Place Colorado
Mengele Donald was found supposedly
Texas.
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck?
That's fucking great.
What?
Shock boy,
that's a stupid movie.
The Meg meg watch that shit.
I watched it the other day.
I could.
I was like,
what am I sit in through here?
Stupid.
There wasn't just one.
There was a bunch of them.
Did get lawyer.
Can you find out how much,
how much media?
Yeah,
I have.
I was struggling to find that and then I
think I found what you found.
So it says,
here's from NASA's website,
there's 100 tons of dust and sand sized
particle every day.
Hit Earth every day,
but every day it seems like it would put
the balance of the earth off,
you know,
like you know what I mean?
Like are we sending shit back out into
space and we send them 100 tons of shit
back at in the spice everyday to off
load this.
Look at this.
Every two years,
a thousand years or so,
immediate meteoroid the size of a
football field hits earth and caused
significant damage to the area.
That's scary.
Once every faculty in the next 10
minutes and object large enough to
threaten earth's civilization comes
along.
Not just that bigger than that impact
craters on earth.
The moon and other planetary planetary
bodies are evidence of these
occurrences.
Yeah.
They don't even know.
You know,
that's the most spooky thing.
Like Neil degrasse Tyson said that we
are decades away from being able to do
anything about one of those things
coming our way,
and I said,
so all these people that think that they
could stop it when it's happening,
it's not happening.
He goes,
there's nothing you could do.
What about Armageddon,
Bro?
The Bruce Willis?
Yeah.
We've got solar swells up there.
He'll figure it out.
Sort that.
Yeah.
There's a.
people have a real distorted idea of the
technological capabilities in terms of.
First of all,
NASA,
so under budgeted,
they barely have enough money to put
satellites in orbit.
They don't have enough money to stop
asking me coming in and mean the amount
of money you would need is so fucking
massive.
It would take a cooperative joint effort
of every major country in the world is
such a force of nature,
a force of nature.
You usually can't be fucked with scary.
Well,
they're all.
They can do all they think they could do
in the and not
even now,
but in the future is move it off target
slightly to somehow or another,
give it a bump,
send it into Mars or something at a
certain distance and completely misses.
Yeah.
Cracks and noon instead of darkness to
light for forever.
Yeah.
It's scary spaces scary and you don't
really see space unless you're out there
with no light pollution,
you know the,
I don't think people that don't camp or
that you don't go,
you know,
you look up at night,
like last night,
well not last night but a couple of
nights ago when it wasn't raining,
it was a clear night and I saw quite a
few stars because it was no moon.
I was like,
wow,
so pretty,
but it ain't shit.
But you're not seeing the volume over.
Yeah.
It's photos that you have added my farm.
You can just sit there with the naked
eye and you can look right into those.
There's so many stars and it looks like
a dark spot of the Milky Way because you
can see so much of it.
You know,
you see color in it and everything gets
an amazing spot.
Now the color's weird,
right?
What is the color?
What is that out?
And I was,
I looked at some photos of it.
Oh,
not my own photos.
Someone else's photos and that will show
on the,
the roar images and the color that was
coming out of these raw images.
They look like absolute pill is like
painted pillars.
Dude.
You know,
and it's odd and I don't know if it's a
debt financier,
if it's something like that.
Jamie put go to Adam.
The first man.
Instagram again like these,
like the ones of.
Oh look at that one from BC.
Go Down one strip that,
that one there.
That's with the northern lights in it.
Wow.
But yeah,
that's sad.
No light pollution out there.
Obviously you saw the northern lights
and DC.
I didn't know you could see him in BC.
I thought you had to be in like
icelander assumption.
That was cool.
I've seen him when I was in northwest
territories are lighting up the ground
like and right in front of your eyes.
I would just like dance and constantly
right in front of your eyes.
That was awesome.
In the Northwest Territories of
Australia now in Canada.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Northern territories of Australia.
Right.
That's what they call it.
The last is.
Okay.
So where's it at the best though?
Is that the best place to see it in like
Iceland or some shit or Norway and I
don't know.
I've seen it.
I've seen it in northwest territory.
These.
I've seen it.
The NBC.
I don't think we didn't say it in
Alberta when will there?
No,
but I think we had shitty with a wall
with it.
Yeah.
It's got to be a crazy thing to see
though.
Huh?
It's like green smoke in the sky.
Yeah.
If you go down a couple more,
Jamie,
please
silent.
That is the,
that there's the farm.
Go up one.
Yeah.
Hit that one in the middle there.
Wow.
Look at the car and not one.
Ah,
that's amazing.
And is that what kind of.
You have to do something with the
aperture?
Well for starters,
it's open for longer,
so it's cavern in more light,
you know,
like the human eye,
you to actually lie there in the dark
for a fire wall and just stare into
that.
Sort of get a good look at it.
How long is it open to get that image?
That's like a 13 or 15 seconds.
Oh Wow.
Yup.
You can leave it open for 30 seconds or
you can put it on like a actual jammed
on open for a long time,
but it's way too much light for what the
farm has and you can start getting a lot
of distortion as well.
That's such a cool picture with the
cabin as well.
With the light coming out of the cabin.
Isn't that crazy that there could be
infinite earths out there?
Yeah,
that's what's crazy.
Is that each one of those is a son.
Yeah.
And most of them are bigger mean
apparently.
Our son is a little bitch ass son,
son.
Thank God for that.
I was.
There will be fraud.
You just have to be further away,
but the big ones don't last that long.
Apparently Our signs a good one.
It's a,
it's like a,
it's like a Toyota tercel
shit.
Fucking last is a high luck.
We don't have that over here.
Yeah.
You got like the,
the chemo.
Yeah.
Lux is like a small Land Cruiser,
right?
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
I've got a bunch of wacky.
The cruise is probably bet on the bat.
Boy,
Land Cruiser.
That's the high luck today.
The new Land Cruiser.
The tribe back though.
So like a dual cab.
So lucked five seats but it's got to try
on it.
And then the tray,
uh,
you mean like a pickup truck bed?
Like a pickup truck bed.
But we usually the,
the,
the one that's on it off,
we usually grip the truck,
the pickup truck bed off because it's
like,
it's bulky,
you know,
there's not a lot of room in it really
usually rip that off.
And we'll build a steel tray.
So it's like a whole flatbed.
You might call it a flatbed and uh,
you can just feed a lot more on it and
it's a lot more rickety,
you know,
you can throw rocks on it.
Whatever the fuck you want.
Well you guys have to have vehicles that
you could drive for like a day before
you hit a gas station if you do on that
ap doing those hunts that I do.
Yeah.
So one of the first things you do is you
rip off the fuel tank and you put like
an aftermarket fuel tank on it.
That's usually like twice the capacity.
Well you fro a second fuel tank on it
and go from there.
So I don't know what are these in
gallons,
but like say a fuel tanks,
like usually 60 liters,
20 gallons is what usually a fuel tanks
out here.
Well then we'd double up to like 40 or
50 or 60 or something like that.
And because it's such a market for it in
Australia,
there's a bunch of them that you buy
ready that already the man onto your
vehicle.
Why is there a market for that in
Australia?
Because it's fucking 100 miles to
anyway.
I'm full driving's like different in
Australia as well,
you know,
it's like.
So where my business is the nearest
city,
which is perse,
like 18 hours drive,
you know,
and then we feel teen.
It was drive to the nearest city.
Yup.
Eighteen hours,
18 hours.
What is that Jamie?
That's too far.
But what would it take us to get?
That's like Colorado.
I've driven a car.
I've driven from Ohio to here twice in
33 hours and 24 hours gets you from
Columbus to about Amarillo,
Texas.
And at 24 hours of straight driving,
straight driving.
Geez.
Western Australia is like a massive
site.
It goes from the very top of Australia
to the very bottom of a steroid.
I feel like when you get out of the car
for 33 hours of driving sucks so bad.
One time we ended at four in the
morning,
right on the sunset strip,
right at that hotel.
The Hyatt.
Wow.
Five in the morning.
But when you get in La at four in the
morning,
you're right in the traffic again.
You're like tired as shit.
You're like,
oh,
it's time to go.
You gotta go because you're about to
record at the end of the trip,
but you pump,
you pump in Columbia,
the hallway though,
actually
it's a helies drive and it's just,
you know,
to some people that's nothing the whole
way,
but it's beautiful country.
Like if you're in the outback you
utilize stare staring out and you happy
the whole time.
It's not a very popular thing to do in
Australia to go out into the outback and
it is,
yeah,
between like four drive and like tearing
and theories.
Ious and like we call them the gray
nomads,
so like older people that have retired.
We have gray hair like all nights.
Been great young.
Jamie.
I ain't looking so young.
But um,
a gray nomad we call them,
you know,
they'll get like a normal description in
Australia.
Yeah.
We saw these grey nomads out there.
People go,
okay,
don't say it.
The gray nomads.
So no,
no,
but if you said it went to the gas
station,
like you see anybody out that.
Yeah,
we saw some normal people know what
you're saying,
Huh?
Yeah.
Now I'm do most people that would do
this,
do they,
are they just going out there camping?
Just camping,
getting,
getting a good,
you know,
influx of the outdoor sort of thing,
getting a hit.
It seems like there is quite a bit of
hunting,
you know,
Australia though,
like particularly there is hunting seems
to be on the rise.
Yeah.
It's just not really promoted will sit
for,
you know,
the boating community itself.
Whereas you come to America and those
towns with big sign up saying welcome
hunters,
you know,
and it's promoted.
Yeah.
It's not,
it's like it's not part of our history
in Australia even though it is signs
that say,
welcome onto in America,
have you seen in Australia there's none
of that.
Yeah,
that's what I meant.
So I think it is on the rise,
you know,
and I think there's like this bit of a
trend at the moment,
you know,
go and kill your own,
which is good.
I love that.
Well socially,
because Australia has so many non native
species that you can hunt.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And mean you don't ever have to buy meat
in Australia.
No,
do you ever buy meat if we're eating
chicken?
Yeah,
that's about it,
but just to mix it up.
Yeah.
The fridge is full.
I feel only friends fridge's me
families.
Fridges.
Speaking of chicken,
what's that?
Mountain Lion Tastes fucking
delicious.
That's what I keep hearing is delicious
and people get angry.
It's so strange to me how angry people
get if you kill them.
Outline because I think they think that
if you kill it,
it's different than killing a deer or
something.
That's a normal thing to eat.
Even more than a bear.
They get more angry.
So kittycat.
Yeah.
Meanwhile that motherfucker
killed.
I had a bunch of people sign,
you know,
you shouldn't have killed a lion.
See Mountain lions,
like I say,
dear fucking know shit because if you
seen mountain lions like you've seen
deer,
there'd be no dear.
It's as simple as that.
You know?
I don't know what the numbers are,
but there's probably supposed to be like
one mountain line for every 500 deer or
something like that.
That's real hard and there are sneaky
creature,
you know,
you're not supposed to see them.
They're not like that.
Listen,
you,
you could go your whole life
not seeing them and they can be around
you all the time.
It's a fact.
If you live in the wilderness,
if you live in Montana or you live in
Colorado and you live in the woods,
you might see one every few years.
You might have one every few years and
they all fucking everything.
Yeah,
I'll say prince all the time,
but I'll never say a cat like I've
actually never seen a cat in a wall
except for the one that I hunted.
And let's like that story I was telling
you before,
like it was eating a cough,
but they typically kill a deer every
single day.
So it's fucking deer.
This,
the human brian allows us to manage
things in a certain way,
you know,
and it's like these biologists and put
all of these study and research in the,
you know,
going,
okay,
you can hunt males in this area.
So that's all I could hunt where I was.
I could only shoot a mile.
How do you know it's a male?
Well,
that's when the dogs come in handy.
So like I've always,
I've never really wanted to hunt with
dogs because I'd like to do all the
hunting myself,
but
there's a special bond between the
hunter and the dogs when you're hunting
those fisher.
And it was actually a really good
experience.
I really loved it.
But a lot of people frown on using dogs,
but the best way to to determine the sex
is the dogs will track it and the line
will take refuge in a tree and then you
can have a look at of genitals and make
sure it's a male with binoculars.
Yeah,
yeah.
Or sometimes if they low enough you can
tell if the human.
Alright.
So the first thing we established was,
will.
It was the line that I wanted the lion
that had killed that calf was eating
that calf alive.
We ended up getting the,
getting the rancher to come in and he
ended up putting the coffee out of its
misery.
It couldn't be saved.
And then we put the dogs back on that
mountain lion track and Knight chased
him about seven miles and I ended up
training.
We got,
we marched in and hiked into Detroit and
ended up determining that it was a mile
and then um,
I ended up shooting and it wasn't really
good deaf,
it was quick,
but um,
if it was a female would have had to
have left,
uh,
where we were.
Some states aren't like that and
counties aren't like that where it can
be male and female of the population is
too high.
What they're trying to do in that part
of Colorado is just keep that mountain
lion population healthy and how they
determined that was by shooting miles
honestly,
that could change next year I could have
a rise in mountain lion,
a decrease in the mule deer and other
animals.
So they might change that again,
but we could only shoot them mail.
So yeah.
The problem in America,
particularly in California where they
outlawed hunting with dogs,
is that the perception of using a dog to
go after an animal,
the perception is that it's not fair
what people.
I mean,
this is going to be hard for some
people,
especially animal lovers to understand,
but that is the only effective way to
hunt for mountain lions because there's
no way you're going to sneak up on them.
You're just not.
You're not going to see that.
That's when numbers start to bloom and
other animals like mule deer and stuff
started to plummet.
We talked about it.
A lot that's happening in California is
the mule deer population has been
decimated because there's no control on
the mountain lions,
so they do have control of the mountain
lions,
but only government employees killed in
the mountain lion kill.
Ironically,
the same amount of mountain lions they
were killing when they were hunting is
sign.
It's insane,
but instead of people paying money to do
it and getting it ties back into
conservation and getting to eat the
mount line,
which I know again,
people like,
what are you talking about?
Eating mountain line.
I'm telling you folks,
I haven't eaten one,
but I'm telling you and you said it.
Brunello said it's one of the most
delicious animals he's ever eaten.
Yeah.
I wanted to bring us on,
but it's actually illegal to bring it in
to California.
Good thing.
We always abide by the law,
have green tree and then one day I'll
try it,
so then I've cooked it up and I'm
feeding it to Kim and I was cooking
chicken as well just in case her and the
kids didn't like it.
I had chicken on the grill as well and I
said the mountain line first and now
we're eating the mountain lion and I'm
like,
what do you think of it?
And she's like,
I've got the chicken,
and I'm like,
no you don't.
You've got the mountain line.
And it was delicious.
Dude.
It's tenderize.
I felt like it was a tie between like
chicken and pork or chicken and even
venison,
like I found it right in the middle
there.
It's delicious and I'm not saying
everyone should go out and hunt and
mountain along because you can't do
that,
but there's certain places that you can
go and get a tag for the benefit of
wildlife and gun hunter mountain line.
People just have a hard time with the
idea that you are somehow or another
helping to control the population by
killing an animal that kills other
animals.
Yeah.
The weird.
They would rather let nature take its
course,
but so even if like like let's go to
Africa now,
even if the lion population why out wide
something and was running it to
extinction,
these people would want to sit back and
just let that happen and it's like
humans have got a brain capacity to
allows us to study and put research into
an animal that's like actually what
would it be more healthier for?
The whole ecosystem would be if we come
in and hunt these animals and what we'll
do is we'll charge people a certain tag
fee to be able to do that and we'll put
that back into conservation which will
help this animal and then there's just
this beautiful healthy bowl that keeps
turning for the people that
no it.
They respect it and they appreciate it.
You know,
people like back country hunters and
anglers and all these different
organizations.
Rocky Mountain Elk Federation,
a lot of different organizations.
They have in United States that really
appreciate what they're doing to promote
that idea here in America,
but people that don't hunt and don't
don't go into me.
It took me years to kind of wrap my head
around it and really truly understand it
and become educated as to how it works
and that wildlife biologists set these
standards and they do it based on
healthy populations and how much time
they spend doing surveys and analyzing
the population,
how important it is to,
you know,
these reports and hunter send into
wildlife organizations and the
department of fish and game.
It's really interesting stuff
and I'm not a blanket killer even
because I understand where those people
are coming from as well.
We need a certain amount of that because
it could go the opposite way where it's
like just go out and hunt everything and
it's not the case.
If something's not in a good healthy
population.
I'm not interested in hunted over all
myself.
Of course.
I want to say these animals stay here
for forever.
I want my kids,
kids,
kids to be able to see those animals in
good health.
Healthy population.
Yeah.
Look,
when I hear you
about limited entry tags for like,
like for Moose or something like that
because there's a small number and
they'll let a certain amount of people.
What?
Fuck you do.
Adam green trees,
ages that Kombucha is a tale.
He has.
This happened now I'm a slob.
That's why the towels here.
I fucking spill everything.
I've.
I've ruined two laptop at least.
At least two laptops during the show.
She gets angry.
That's like it's angry.
Americans.
Dangerous.
It is fucking Kombucha.
GTS conclusions.
Going back to the coffee
I found out like,
like in some places they have a small
amount of Moose and they'll let you hunt
a moose but it has to be like one moose
and it has to be over 50 inches and like
I'm out.
I don't want to shoot that Moose.
How many of them are there?
There's 200 of them.
Fuck out of here.
I'm not shooting.
You know what if,
what if the winter comes and kills a
bunch of them off?
Like which happens would have wolves
move in happens.
Yeah.
And that's why these tag limits in that
change from year to year as well.
Like I've seen them constantly change
because that will do the research or the
kill wasn't big enough last year or the
winner was too harsh and you know,
they start limiting and tags.
Yeah.
That's very sad.
I think in most cases,
in most cases we've got it right.
Yeah,
I think so too.
What's one of the reasons why one of my
favorite places to hunt as alumni
because Linda did so out of whack with
fucking spotted little demons that just
jump out of the white arrows constantly.
It's crazy of an animal that evolved to
get away from tigers.
You can't believe how fast those Goddamn
and delicious.
Yeah.
He was saying it's a,
it's,
it's kind of a weird coincidence that
the fastest you can hunt,
it's also the most delicious.
Yeah.
Oh totally.
That's kind of weird because they are
delicious.
They learned to move faster.
I think a d,
so you know,
we say jumped the string like when you
shoot like the dia,
he is the Bogo off or something like
that and we call it jumped the string,
which you'll know about this,
but a lot of people want.
They don't actually don't jump out of
the string.
When I miss you,
I heard that actually dropped to bound
the why.
So they drop load up their legs and then
jen jump.
But it's actually the drop.
That's when you usually miss him.
Will that moves that over 1300 feet per
second.
A really good bowl shoots at about 300
feet per second in a hunting situation.
So you can't beat them 13,
1300 feet per second.
That's how fast they stopped dropping.
That's insane.
Well the thing about access deer as
opposed to any other animal I've ever
hunted is they don't just jump the
string.
They get out of the way.
Yeah.
The whole body length,
like yeah,
like you have to date,
they have to not know you're there.
Like the first one that I killed this
season had no idea was there no idea.
No idea was there and there's a nice
wind,
so when that Arrow hit him,
he was quarter in a way.
When that hit him,
he had no idea it was common to perfect
it.
Was that a trip or a different one?
Yeah,
that was.
That was when I got out of the car and I
saw 1:15 minutes.
You have big velvet,
so I try and it's assigned.
We fell idea back in Australia.
Like they've really fast off the mark.
I'll try and shoot them when they busy,
you know when they've got other noise
happening,
they write in their aunt Lou's stepping
forward or something like that.
And the few that I shot in Lanai,
one was scuffling with another Bach,
so he was old busy and he didn't move at
all and it pegged him.
The avalon was he in high wind in the
grass and it had the grass like moving
around it and he didn't move and then
the third one was on a really still die
and I actually I am for his heart and he
dropped an I end up hitting you in
double lungs.
It's just they're so quick.
It's like you need to calculate even
right at the moment when you're looking
gun to shoot,
it was like you need the white for
something extra to happen,
you know?
Yeah.
Well it's a great place to get accustom
to stalking and hunting animals with a
bow tie because the opportunities are so
many.
Yeah.
You blow on your like I'll move onto the
next one.
There's 20,000 deer and 3000 people.
It's tiny little island.
Yeah.
Did you,
did you ever go out at night in a car
when you see the other side of the road?
I think,
I think I was in the car with you and
there was like $400 common across the
road and it's just like all these little
lies just going
nonstop.
Didn't even make sense and they hire
people to go in there with sniper
rifles,
so just take them out one after another.
It's crazy.
And then something that's always got to
me.
So like one of the property owners that
lives beside my property where a hunt,
he'll go out and [inaudible] dear vermin
in Australia and they've just been
declassified.
They classified and those game animals
for a year or a couple
of years now,
they've just declassify them because the
numbers are just exploding.
So you can shoot them under the lights.
You can,
you can do anything.
You can feed them,
you can buy them,
you can do whatever you want.
You want to get rid of them.
And uh,
so this guy,
he raises cattle and uh,
so that's what he has.
He'll go out at night and he'll shoot
these deer and just leave them right
where they lay,
not take any meat off more than anything
but then kill one of his own cattle to
fill these freezer and fridge.
And the first time he'd actually eight
and venison was when I shot.
I shot a deer on his property and I cut
it up and I actually gave it to him.
That was the first time you'd ever eaten
venison deer.
And unlike John,
you had like killing your own cattle,
these delicious meat sitting right there
as this walled resource.
And it's renewable because they fuck
each other.
They buried.
Yeah.
And so he's eating his own cattle and
selling them.
Yeah.
And now the thing is this,
another way that I've always looked at
it is these walled animals have there,
whether you like it or not,
they're there.
Why place another cow or another sheep
in the paddock to put strain on the
landscape if you,
especially if you ate and your own.
Why not just go and shoot a d?
It's a wild animal and you're doing the
ecosystem of service by doing it.
And there is some of the most healthy
animals.
Delicious.
They're super healthy for you.
They're so rich in vitamins and
nutrients and protein and the tea.
I prefer it over everything.
Yeah.
I really do.
Yeah,
and it's not just the taste,
it's that whole feeling thing.
Like,
I went and got this,
I earned this,
I killed this.
I know where this comes from.
You're attached to.
It was spoken about it before,
but when you get mate that served in a
package at the supermarket that goes for
pass hundreds and hundreds of people's
hands and breaths and stuff like that,
you know,
it's just like having sex with scarlet
Johanson and the virtual reality to a
guy that's the next detachment.
The fucking.
It's going to be made instead of made.
It's going to be sick.
Says the next detachment.
Well there's a,
there's these people that are making
artificial meat now are not just
artificial,
I shouldn't say artificial.
It's real meat,
but it's meat that's made in a lab and
that's the,
I don't know what they're calling an
ethical meat or whatever the fuck
they're calling it,
but it's the future of,
of meat production and you know,
this is making animal rights people very
excited because they're basically gonna
have just lapped me.
That's so fucking.
Yeah.
So you know,
it's gonna happen.
No more cows,
no more domestic pig's name on the shit
that they love.
Like the reason that cows there is
because there's a demand for meat.
So that cow gets a life because there's
mate.
Right?
No one's going to let these cows and
sheep and domestic pigs and sheep
running around on their landscape and
take out real estate if there's no
market for.
Pigs are the weirdest one because pigs,
like my friend Whitney Cummings,
she adopted a pig that.
Where'd she get that pig?
I think it was from the fire,
right?
Yeah,
and she actually wound up driving it to
Texas.
She drove in her car 24 hours.
She's a fucking maniac when it comes to
animals.
I think her and her fiance drove Texas
with this fucking pig to drop it off at
this pig shelter and damn dude,
when she's with that pig,
that thing is like a dog.
Might as well be.
My dog is like hanging out there animal
yet,
but when they get loose and they're out
in the wild boy,
they fucking breed three,
four times a year.
They'll have big piles of piglets and
piglets will destroy.
They eat everything in sight there.
Omnivorous,
devastating thing for everything to
devastating to plants and ground nesting
birds,
animals,
everything.
They eat everything in front of them.
They're pigs.
Yeah,
and I hate them.
I got a height on love pigs.
I think they're an unread animal,
but the bigger picture is I need to be
controlled.
They can't go out there and just ruined
the ecosystem like that.
Well,
there's.
You're seeing in Texas,
Texas is probably in the United States
is the biggest example of what happens
when or the best example.
What happens in these feral hogs are
just completely out of control.
They just devastate these agricultural
farms.
They have these farms and they're just
getting destroyed.
God
life.
Other wildlife as well because I hate
frogs and now lean lizards now.
Anything that on the ground that's
edible about Ada.
Yeah.
I wrote an article years ago.
It was cold
killer at the pos.
It was a place in Australia and the the
property owners like the ranch has
called me out and I said,
you need to come out and shoot some of
the boxes.
Like they'd devastating our lambs and I
ended up going out there and when I was
driving in with a forward drive at night
with the high beams on,
I seen this massive big black and white
bull walking between the flock of sheep
with a laminate to mouth.
It was these pig and it had got a taste
for meat and it happens all the time.
Like so a big bull,
especially in mature animal will get a
taste for meat in harsher conditions.
Now just stick the meat off to that.
And I ended up catching up with these
pig the next morning and shot it with
the bow.
It actually attacked me.
The first shot wasn't perfect and it
charged me and I ended up stabbing it to
death.
I was on a slope like this on the
mountain cheese and it was really a
battle like any high end up hooking the
ball out of my hand because when he
charged me I'll put an Erewhon and shot
and just went down one side and hit one
lung.
And it just infuriated this bowl and he
was on me.
And um,
when I was fending them off with the
bow,
he's tasked,
went into the bottom,
limit the bow or the cam or something
like that and rip the bone out of my
hand.
And I ended up getting me knife off me
and I ended up stabbing this pig was
electronic,
run me over.
Oh Shit.
How big was it?
It was a big boys big meeting.
It made eight and bullet like this.
And like how many pounds?
A fucking big 10.
Many pounds.
300.
Probably not 300 and mountain bullets
just get real solid.
Yeah,
probably $200.
Something like that.
And anyway,
I ended up stabbing this thing to death
and when I ended up cutting it open its
whole insides,
like it's whole stomach was like
lambs hawks,
like the feet,
the bottom of the feet where they can't
swallow and skulls and just like little
bits of wool and stuff like that.
He'd just been going around and just
picking these lambs often killing them.
And it's a really known occurrence in
Australia.
And how that if things get harsh,
I would just go.
That would just because they,
they just absolutely ruthless.
I would just walk right between the
shape and just fucking grab a lamb
wolkoff chew it up and by.
Anyway,
first thing in that morning that I found
was a pig spew and it was like this
fucking spew like this and it was the
same as lambs hawks and speak to vomit
United States view in America.
You do,
but I wasn't.
I thought it meant something else to
you.
Yeah,
fucking spewing my.
Yeah.
Spewed spewed out what happened at
Disney yesterday.
Butyl on me.
So they just threw up bones just for
bones and stuff that it couldn't digest,
but end up,
yeah,
lamb killer at the destructive animal
and they're so ruthlessly efficient in
terms of like how much food they can.
So a deal walk along and it will pick,
you know,
it would just pick the top soft grass
and the grass regrows,
you know,
a pig will go through and eat that grass
and it'll turn it over and eat the roots
and everything as well.
Causes a lot of erosion and then there's
no great growth because it was my roots
in because they're greedy pigs.
They greedy pigs.
There you go.
But you don't.
They're the number one cause of death on
farms.
Grilling.
Yeah.
Apparently with domestic animals,
people fallen into pig pens and just
into them they just devour and you know,
when you're dealing with these giant
domestic pigs,
they get fucking,
he,
you massive hundreds of pounds in like
Western New South Wales when times get
tough,
which is,
seems to be fucking all the time now.
But um,
they'll get so desperate you'll shoot a
pig on for it for the farmer and you
just shoot it to me.
Not even really taken any made often
because they like,
they can meet their self and they like
skin and bones and disgusting.
It's more of like a commission and
you'll come back in the afternoon and
that pig will be completely skin and
bones [inaudible] the other pigs just
get in there and just.
And you'll hear them,
you'll just hear him just screaming.
It's the most God awful sound there is.
Cannibalize that cannibalize.
Yeah.
I was in to hone ranch and we were
walking by this really high grass grass,
like five foot high and you.
We were only like maybe 10 yards away
from these pigs fighting and I said to.
I said,
no,
come on man.
If you didn't know those were pigs,
if I told you there was demons in that
grass,
you completely believe it.
Something.
Yeah.
That was great.
But it sounded like Lord of the rings.
So like some horrific scene.
Monster movie.
Yeah.
It sounded like it really did.
I mean it's just.
How is that the same animal as those
cute little things that
Whitney Cummings is totally [inaudible]
the one that she had was like all fluffy
and sit in her bed that she taught her
how to go outside and go take the pig is
a pig.
That was the other thing she told me.
Apparently those little pigs are not
real.
All they are is just underfed.
Yeah,
right.
That's pretty fucking.
That's fucked up.
Like when those people have those little
tiny pig,
she's like,
that's not real.
They're just,
Oh,
it's a baby pig.
It's a tiny little pig.
It's just going to stay tiny.
No,
if you don't feed it stayed tiny.
That's about when a memory.
When they had the kittens in the jaws,
I think it was a nice thing or
something.
He'd never seen that.
No.
They had the day were like a little
glass jar and they'd have a cat in the
glass jar I think.
I think they're always fight,
but people advertisement like this is
how you can have your cat.
Holy Fuck.
It looked that up.
Recognition and it's real.
There you go.
Kitty cat.
No,
they afraid
that's fake.
Oh fuck.
Look at that thing.
Xyz.
Okay.
Some of those look real.
So is it just for fun?
There's okay.
They're just before now,
before there was some real ones where
they had the lead on them and
everything.
Well,
you can guarantee somebody got those
fuckers that have got there
blurt out.
Oh,
Jesus Christ,
to apologize for stuffing kitten in a
jar.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Well fuck man.
Yeah,
yeah.
People are capable of incredible
cruelty.
Yeah.
Animals.
That's why we need the upper end of
things.
That's why I say I can understand it.
You know,
you need that other,
like I'm an extreme where I'm just like
on everything,
but I'm sure there's a few people out
there like that.
I've never met them where they just kill
everything.
Then you need the other extreme where
it's like,
no,
all animals are sacred.
Don't touch any animals.
You know,
they can't be killed.
and then try and find that middle ground
where you're like,
well that's fucking ridiculous.
And that's ridiculous.
This is where I am.
I couldn't agree more.
I think that's a perfect way to put it.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
I think a lot of those animal rights
people,
they,
it comes from a good place.
Yeah.
That's how I feel too.
They care about animals that comes from
a good place,
but their understanding of population
control and wildlife management and just
the reality of human beings,
it just,
they just don't think they're getting
it.
With the mountain lion thing,
one of the things they found with
mountain lions in California is that
almost 50 percent of their diet is
domestic pets.
There's go to nature is metal.
Go to nature as metal.com.
My all time favorite instagram page,
so the mountain lion that gets paid
back.
Either he got his page back or they.
He had to open up another one,
but that guy has the most fun
instagram sensitive sensitizing some
sheet at the moment they came,
came ahead of video,
Tony like a 15,
22nd video of her.
It was carrying a white tail deer out in
Texas.
There was no blood on it enough and
you couldn't see that it had been
gathered or anything like that and they
removed it.
Said it was violence.
Okay.
This is nature is metal underscore
backup account.
I don't follow it though,
but yeah,
the other accounts not up anymore.
We'll click on the most recent one.
That lion image.
When is that from?
December 20.
No,
it's new.
It's new.
See if they're back behind back.
Yeah.
Don't go to nature is metal underscore.
Just go to nature is metal.
All metal.
I fought it.
Segmental metal to metal.
Um,
so that's it.
That's the real one.
So scroll up,
keep going.
And that's it right there with the car.
This is the quick and the dead.
This is a Florida panther in this guy's
driveway.
Snatches up a house pet.
Wash.
This shit.
This is what the fuck you have.
This is what the fuck happens.
So This guy's got his security camera
running.
Damn.
That's a wrap.
To wrap a little fella that a dog or a
cat fucking nearly looks like a cat.
It's a kitty cat.
Killed the cat.
Everyone likes to be to put.
See there's a.
How dare you?
There's a,
there's a growing population.
These things,
they're endangered but they're there.
And uh,
you know,
basically,
I mean it's a subspecies I guess,
but it's basically the same thing as a
mountain lion.
Look at them.
The first time I did a little bit of
research in google,
it just comes up that cougars are
endangered in America and but when you
start looking into it then not all there
on the least concern list in America
because the populations for driving and
then when I spoke to a dnr in Colorado
about,
you know,
the cougar as well that was signed,
that they have populations continued to
rise even with the tags that they've
given out.
The po population just continues to rise
and without dogs you're just not going
to hunt them in the way that you might
get lucky and stumble across one.
It's not paying attention to you.
You'd want to have limitless time
though,
you know,
like to actually that's the difference.
You know,
I'd like to have limitless time and then
just be like,
okay,
I'm dedicating a whole month to stalk
and cougars,
you know,
but that's the knock on bear hunting as
well.
The bear hunting,
the 19 nineties,
they outlawed dogs in California.
You can still hunt black bears.
I guess
black bears are more accepted as a
nuisance if the population grows because
you know they'll,
they'll find your garbage and then once
they will say I'm as well,
but yeah,
it's not just that.
Once they find your garbage,
like that'S where they go.
Okay.
Coming back in and day out,
they're there,
they have a pattern and they develop
these habits,
but they stopped using bears,
stopped using dogs rather to hunt bears
in California and then they stopped
using baiting.
So those two things are illegal.
There's no baiting and there's no dog.
So good luck.
Bear hunting.
Yeah.
Especially with the bow.
Pretty tough.
Yeah.
The baiting
ones,
another one,
like people don't like baiting and I get
it,
you know,
we've done it.
It's,
it's,
it's not the same.
No,
It doesn't feel.
It's not as good.
Yeah,
I did it that one time with you.
And then and also like that it was still
good.
It was still cool,
you know,
and there's a tag in place and there's
conservation act in place.
But just arden,
I've got no desire to go back.
I've done that now.
That's cool.
And that conservation is very important
for the elk population.
The moose population,
the deer population,
because they.
They killed an estimated 50 percent of
all moose calves,
elk calves,
dear fonds.
It's all black bears.
Totally.
And they're cannibals too.
They kill cow cubs crazy.
I've watched this one the other day
because you hear people,
I gave a bad child is male climb a tree
and the black bay climbs a tree like,
I mean fucking hall.
I Do.
You have seen it.
And then there's the minimum black bear
and she's got cubs and she goes so fast
up that whole he can't climb up a tree
to get away from a bear.
Yeah,
geT the fuck out of here.
Done the big ones.
Just don't want to do it anymore,
but they could still like it's still do.
It could still do it.
Like the ideas I go to,
the big ones won't chase you up a tree.
When you see the speed that they go up a
tree,
then you can imagine the speed that they
come across land,
you know?
And it's just like,
ah.
Because I always say,
I always Tell people about that one that
was sleeping on an elk kill,
that I had a grizzly.
We showed that video the other day.
Yeah,
yeah.
We showed it on the podcast today and I
remember you or yelled at that grizzly,
the one that was sleeping on the elk
carcass and it fucking disappeared so
fast and quietly.
Dude.
And I'm lucky if you don't have eyes on
one coming at you.
Don't know it's going to come at you
until you hit until it's on your fucking
eight in your face.
All those pads are so soft.
The pads of the feet are so soft in
order to sneak up on things.
I remember the first time I went bear
hunting with cam and one was walking in.
He goes right there,
right there,
right there.
I turned to look.
I'm like,
it's not making noise.
It was like,
oh,
this is a video.
Yeah,
here it is going up.
We're running dude.
Galloping up the true running.
Yeah,
and fucking scary sheet.
It doesn't stop there.
He ended up founding.
Hang on.
That's a black bear with cubs.
So you can imagine that situation with
the grizzly and her cubs,
so fucking scary.
And so that's a color phase.
That looks like a color.
On the top is the black bear cub.
No,
that's it.
I looked like a full grown black bear.
the of color face has got a cub back up
the mountain with a.
Yeah.
That's some crazy shit.
Fucking boy.
toy crocodiles.
Don't fucking climb trees.
That's what I heard.
When are we doing this?
Someone started the petition.
I fucking.
Joe rogan needs a Australia.
yeah.
You keep trying to get me out there.
You've got snakes too though,
bro.
You get sponsors.
Let's fucking go over some shitty.
The whole season is dry.
the whole season in Australia I seen two
snakes.
One of them not poisonous.
It's liKe a red belly.
Black steak.
Not gonna harm.
Your friendly snake.
lawana bailey.
Poisonous snake of heresies.
Barely.
But not very poisonous.
My killer kid or a girl.
The audience know this giant.
ThEy're not going to hurt you.
Talk to them.
Fucking stay out of it.
One thing I wanted to ask you about is
the thylacine the tasmanian tiger.
Yeah.
I read that there was credible reports
by people in the woods.
They might have seen one.
I wish.
I don't think so either,
but it's so remote.
There's so many cameras now.
This guys are scouting cameras that have
putting it over da wallows and stuff
like places that I would come in the
drink.
That was a big animal,
right,
wasn't it?
Yeah.
Big.
Do they get like 100 pounds?
Something like that might be a bit
bigger than that.
What a cool looking dude come on and
thiS.
There it is.
Scientists hunt for extinct tasmanian
tiger after sightings in Australia.
Yeah,
that's probably what I saw.
I wisH the article from what year?
Oh really?
Interesting.
Solid.
The extinction was driven from paypal,
right.
Sounded like because they fucking data
so to come in and start eating sheep or
whatever.
They get shot by farmers and stuff like
that.
Which is a shame and I'm sure that I
didn't realize how do one of the time
but that,
you know,
they pushed them to extinction.
You know,
if there's one thing that we should
bring back from extinction if we,
if it's possible.
I believe they should be brought back if
it's possible,
right.
You have some dna because uh,
I mean that would be nice to have some
sort of an animal like that that could
knock down some of the population goes
and they probably,
I probably wouldn't.
I probably just come in and devastate
our lives populations and shine.
But let me get back to why you need to
come to snakes all year in Australia and
fucking seven,
eight snakes in the first month in
America.
Dude,
17 snyder got bit the other day.
Did he did his boot.
Really?
I Think he was in North Carolina or some
shit,
I forget where it was.
Somewhere in the south and my buddy
dies.
So this is the first hunt that I did
when I come to America.
We flew into Idaho and we drove straight
down to southern Colorado,
the hunt pronghorn and we're driving
into the property at like two.
I am in the morning and there's a
problem home just standing on the side
of the road,
you know,
it's just like a daze,
you know.
So my buddy jay's pulls up,
he walks over to it and like literally
touches it on the head,
like it's like,
it's just like walking down the road and
we're lucky to get hit by a car.
next minute is I see him jump back.
A rattlesnake had bit the pronghorn and
he stood,
he had a leg on neva side of the
rattlesnake in.
It striked him.
It actually strived in twice and both
times
I had to kate question and I'm like,
did that bite you?
And he's like,
nah.
I'm like,
have I think about it?
Did a fucking bite you?
And he's like,
no,
I didn't because I watched it in the
headlights go for him twice.
And uh,
once we set up camp,
we went back there in that problem home
was dead.
Had killed that problem.
Yeah.
I'm like,
fuck America.
America dryer is so much safer.
A friend of mine was a hiking and he
stayed,
almost stepped on a rattle snake and
jumped back and then realize it was a
nest of them whole.
And there was a little one surrounding
them.
They were all over the place.
He was like,
fuck yeah,
jumping,
hopping around one leg after.
No,
no,
I actually had.
Um,
but apparently that happens.
Yeah,
it does.
Yeah.
And trenchless there,
dude.
Everywhere.
There was tris trenches
when over the ground,
everywhere.
It was a bold,
the bold effort to prove the tasmanian
tiger still out there.
Wildlife biologist,
forest gallente has brought one species
back from the dead and he wants to do
the same with the tasmanian tiger.
What the fuck is he brought back from
the dead?
This goddamned frankenstein,
unable to play the cuban saw leno.
Dawn is one of the most curious animals
and plants.
Small,
shrewd,
shrewd.
It must be true like creature memo is a
mammal,
but a highly venomous one.
Fuck.
Can't bring that back to the specimen.
Found those thought to be lost forever.
Then unexpectedly three were caught just
a few years later.
The extinct species marked on.
So that may be the case with the
tasmanian tiger.
Hmm.
It'd be awesome.
I hope so.
Okay.
So here it is.
Galantes a wildlife biologist made his
life mission to search for animals that
have wrongly been deemed extinct and
among those species on his list of the
tasmanian tiger,
a difficulty leads to like who the fuck
is seen once it keeps growing.
So if anybody like legit scene when he's
been traveling around the world,
searching for evidence of species like
tasmanian devil,
a paki lemoore and the new found land,
white wolf still exist.
100 species deemed syncs worldwide,
Annual annually.
This process isn't foolproof and every
now and then animals are rediscovered
after they were thought to be gone
forever.
But proving the animals still out there
is no easy feat.
Hmm.
I wonder.
Huh?
Hope so.
Yeah.
Captured footage of a zanzibar leopard,
which is thought to be extinct for 25
years due to persecution by local
hunters in the zanzibar archipelago in
tasmania.
Tanzania rather.
Excuse me.
Wow.
That would be pretty dope if they
actually did find that thing.
It's a cool looking animal,
you know?
Yeah.
They can't be in good numbers anymore.
I know that much.
Tiny,
tiny number like an animal like that.
Like where did they live?
Tasmania.
That's where the tasmanian tiger.
Tasmania tasmania's.
Where down the bottom
of Australia.
The bottom?
Yeah.
It's a separate island.
Just that tiny little triangle that's
down the bottom.
Absolute beautiful online.
Like that's the only place they lived?
I believe.
So how big is that?
Actually?
They might've been on the mainland and I
think that's where the sightings have
been.
Oh wow.
It's big tazzy how big is that place?
I don't.
No fucking big enough that they don't
allow any bowhunting there.
So I've never gone.
Do they allow hunting?
Yeah,
I think you can hunt with a gun for
fellow.
Do might have they make you use a gun on
it?
Fucking.
No,
I was trying to get some weird rules.
Guns.
Oh yeah.
You guys like have a.
They bought up all the guns after a mass
shooting,
right?
Well,
not all of them.
If you have a license holder,
like a shoot to shoot his license and
you had a reason to have a gun,
then you can still keep your guns.
So you had to be like a member of a gun.
I don't own any guns,
but you had to be a member of a gun
club.
I don't own any guns in Australia.
Uh,
you had to be a member of a gun club,
have or perhaps mission on a property
where you're hunting and stuff like that
to keep the guns as they keep trying to
make it tighter and tighter.
I think it's hard enough because
criminals are going to get what they
want,
right.
You know,
it's lIke how many people have been
killed with baseball bat
fucking heaps.
Or you're going to be in baseball bats
having people who've been killed with a
kitchen knife,
you're going to bend kitchen knives.
So I think if you've got a legitimate
reason to have a gun,
you know,
like you don't have a criminal record,
you don't have a mental illness or
something like that.
You should have a right to have a gun.
So you do basically do a safety course
and training in Australia and if you've
got that reason to have a rifle and you
can have it,
no semiautomatics,
um,
there's a bunch of rifles and there's a
bunch of guns that you can't have in
Australia.
It's pretty much like bolt action,
lever action and those rules might have
changed as well.
No expert on it obviously.
Whereas in America,
every fucking one's got an error on a
mate's.
Got a gun.
I've got a gun too,
because if everyone else has got a goal
I want a fucking gun to.
It's true isn't a true and my guns for
protection when I go into the wilderness
for bears or if I'm fucking in some weed
destination,
someone comes in and tries to fucking
rape and murder my family,
I'm going to use it.
And uh,
yeah,
it's just funny Like that.
But it's crazy to think and I know it
changes from place to place that anyone
could have a gun because you know,
it's like,
you're right.
and to a certain degree,
I agree with that.
But uh,
as well,
I think you lose that right?
If you've got a criminal record,
you've got a mental illness or something
like that,
then fuck.
Yeah,
exacTly.
We want good guys with guns.
Not bad guys with guns,
but bannon guns using,
going to stop the bad guys from having
guns.
It's like trying to take p out of the
pool.
Yeah,
it's fucking so much.
there's too many now.
When you,
uh,
when you hunt in Australia,
you're not allowed to use a bolt action
rifle.
You can use a bolt action rifle,
like the automatic semI automatic I
think in ar.
Ar,
yeah.
I think pump actions have been taken out
now.
Things like that.
Yeah.
Huh?
Because I want to feel like if,
especially with population control,
something like fallow deer,
if you have that many of them,
I know there's places that are just
erupting with them.
You'd have to shoot him,
right?
Yeah,
totally.
Yeah.
I mean there's no way you're going to
have a lot of places.
It's like the whole California thing,
you know,
they're still getting killed,
but it's just a professional hitman
that's doing it now.
That's not the right recreation behind
it.
And in Australia,
a lot of the times it's like a good
example is actually across the pond in
New Zealand where they like,
fuck,
we need to shoot 30,000 ta,
you know,
tyler leavinG the mountains and because
they are introduced or introduced and
uh,
I don't think there was a lot of hunt is
arguing at the time and no one was
really arguing that we needed to shoot
some tar,
but we weren't like fucking shoot 30,000
of them because they shoot him from a
helicopter and I leave him rod on the
mountain.
They don't use any of it.
It's just a massive waste of resource,
you know,
and it's like you're never going to
eradicate them all anyway.
And why?
Why didn't want to shoot 30,000 of them?
Well,
they're introduced for starters in
fucking politicians work of money and
fucking having a job to do.
So michael loaded these things up,
you know.
But I would think that the money would
be in higher or people paying to go and
hunt them.
Some of these towns live off hunters
like that.
Any reason that town,
he said like all their income is hunt
hunters coming in hunting these
destinations and uh,
that's the reason why the animals are
there in the first place in New Zealand.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
They were all introduced as by wealthy
europeans.
They wanted to make it look a hunting
distAnce.
Yeah,
that's right.
It's so crazy.
They just threw a bunch of.
This is our playground.
What's up?
Fuck.
Well,
new zealand's is happy for now because
they've got something to hunt game
animals.
But um,
if they're truly causing that much
damage,
then yes,
obviously like feeling out the
population,
but why not get hunt is involved to do
it.
Why not promote hunting,
you know,
where the meat gets used with it were
done properly in benefits the
communities and where there's a lot of
hunting destinations in New Zealand
where people go to that are high fence
places,
which is a little weird because they're
like just.
I mean,
even if it's a couple hundred acres or a
couple of times they're fenced in and
those aren't going anywhere.
It's just different.
It's like what we're talking about
before where there's like shallow fun,
like I've never done it,
but I'd say that as like a shallow fun
and then there's meaningful funds.
Fucking walk the mountain,
find your own spot,
you know?
Well be actual.
Actually go into the wild.
Don't fence the wild and,
and make it the not wild.
Don't make it the domestic.
The hard bit.
The hard bit about saying that you're
caucasian if you do it.
He's at benefit.
Some wildlife,
like there's yes and shit that have been
brought back from the concern list or
nearly extinction because defense
operations like in Texas,
in africa.
Oh yeah.
So it's like,
I suppose it has got its place but it's
just,
there's different.
There's different sorts of hunters.
Well there's also different sizes of
these partitions.
So like if you're in a place like
there's some places in Texas that are
10,000 acres,
like look that's so far beyond that.
Animals wild range thAt you might as
well be in a wild.
Even if there's a fence,
you know,
80 miles in that direction,
what the fuck are you ever going to get
to that fence or a deer?
You're not going to.
Yeah,
it's true.
I think I'm.
Maybe I'm a little bit closed minded on
it.
It's the same thing.
To me,
it's like ideologically the same thing.
I agree with you.
It feels I've,
you know,
I've seen those places.
It seems weird.
It's like jurassic park.
You go through these giant gates and
inside those animals are fenced in.
They never getting out.
You know,
they're in there.
There's no mystery,
there's no mystery.
That's.
And I like,
I liked the file.
You're in hunting as much as I liked the
success.
If you call like killing an animal to
success,
but you know,
I liked that.
The opportunity and you do everything in
you fucking pals steal your work your
ass off.
You know,
you're fucking figured to bleed if they
have to do,
to get to the end of it.
But I liked the idea that you can still
file in a hunt and I locked filing on a
hunt sometimes because it makes you
realize,
fuck,
this is hard.
So the next time imagine everything gets
shot out.
Just smoked a fucking.
Give it away in a day.
I wouldn't be interested in.
It will be like farming.
That's right.
I liked that file you because it makes
you realize how fucking old somebody is
when you get something.
Well,
it also,
it's different between hunting in any
other way that you get meat because
because it is so difficult and It
requires skill planning,
intelligence,
you have to have knowledge.
You have to know how to play the wind.
You have to know when to move,
when to not move.
It's a tactical situation where you have
to use the right tactics to get in on
this animal or it was going to smell you
or hear you or see you.
There's so muCh involved in it that's
not involved.
If you're just acquiring meat and the
other way and that's what it should take
two,
because we have taken an animal's life
so it should take that effort,
you know,
and then it's like you put so muCh heart
and soul into it that even if you cut
the meat up and is like roddy and puffy,
like,
fuck,
this is delicious.
Yeah.
Well you were talking about your elk
hunt in New Mexico this year and how
difficult it was and you guys were out
there for over a month.
Yeah.
Well we did.
We did a Oregon.
We did New Mexico and we did Montana for
elk and which is like boston.
How awesome.
the whole time,
you know.
and then I ended up getting one though.
It was like the one I actually really
just wanted kim to get a shootable
hoofers ball because she's been going at
it.
And uh,
the one afternoon that she took off
because she was doing some homeschooling
with the kids and trying to get on top
of all that,
the perfect opportunity popped up and I
ended up shooting his bowl and then we
never had a good opportunity again.
You know,
we just stopped.
But the thing is that that's made a
hungrier for it next,
this season,
you know,
like she realizes how hard are.
They just have difficulties in general.
Appreciate it much more.
That's what it should be.
Well,
it's cool that she is determined that
it's not discouraging her,
that the difficulty oftentimes for a
lot of people that difficulty because
it's,
you know,
you're,
you're out there seven days,
10 days,
your feet are killing you.
You're exhausted.
You,
you're like,
I'm just going to go to the fucking
soup.
I'm going to get a rifle.
Yeah.
Kim is actually a really good example of
what a lot of your audience would be
because kim's really been that city
girl,
you know,
like,
that's,
that's just been a life,
you know.
And then I had,
it took about seven years to convince
her to eat fucking venison game.
Yeah.
And how I did it was I shot a deer and
it was just like a nice healthy young
deer.
And I cut the back straps in the
caitlyn,
so I think you guys call them tomahawk
steaks.
So we call them color.
It's like cut it into cutlets and it
just looked like lamb cutlets.
Dude.
And I cooked up these land cutlets and I
served it and she fucking loved it.
Like her and the kids were just like,
this is delicious.
I think I actually only had my oldest
boy hunter at the time,
like this delicious.
And I loved it.
And then unlike that's venison that d,
because it was just the images,
I hide it,
but I had no idea what the meat tastes
like.
She had no idea shooting cute little
deer.
yeah.
Yeah.
And now it's the opposite where she
doesn't feel as comfortable eating an
animal that she doesn't know about,
you know,
because if,
if we put venison in the fridge freezer
like an ava goes past just kim's handle
my hands,
that's it.
You know,
where the animal come from,
you know that it was healthy,
you know,
everything like that.
And Then coconut and eaten it and she
feels a lot more.
And I'm not trying to Put anyone down at
buys me because like I said,
I still buy me too and there's nothing
wrong with that.
That's the population of the world
demands that.
But there's something that you don't
feel as guilty about cooking your own
meals.
There's some sort of connection there
that goes way beyond my birth,
you know.
Whereas like a real connection with
hunting and eating the meat.
My littlest daughter loves fishing,
loves it and loves it.
We go fishing together and we caught
yellow tail in Hawaii.
Nice cooked it.
Had the chef actually cook it in turn.
We stayed at a hotel and you bring it to
the chef and the at the restaurant and
he would make shimmy out of it and made
some j and it was so good,
but she loves it.
She loves it.
She caught something and brought it in
and she wants everyone to know that
you're eating something that she caught.
Yeah.
It's so cool.
That's a good feeling.
Well,
it's also connecting her with the what,
what a fish is,
you know,
you go,
she likes sushi.
She's had sushi before.
now she's having sushi that she was
there when the thing died,
she caught it.
She pulled it out of the ocean.
You know,
we took the hook out of it's mouth.
We filleted it like the whole deal.
She saw shot every step of the way,
you know,
so
they're still like a connection in
paypal.
That's like it sparks up again when I do
something because we'd done that for
forever forever.
When you catch a fish,
when it's on the,
like the excitement,
like it doesn't necessarily even make
sense if there's not some sort of a
genetic component to it because the
excitement is so visceral.
It's so like it's genetic
bad.
It's like what'd you do on pulling into
law and it's got some light on it.
Been spin
on the.
First of all she wouldn't let anyone
help her.
She like wanted to do it her.
She's awesome and she's got a 10 pound
yellowtail and this thing
and I'm helping her by holding onto the
rock.
That's all I'm doing because
you know,
so I'm holding the rod to make sure it
doesn't.
And she's got two hands on the crank and
she's.
But she wouldn't give up.
I go,
what do you want me to help you?
just like,
no,
that's awesome.
Yeah.
She was so determined because when she
did do it and brought it in,
the thrill was so powerful.
She wanted to be the one that brought it
in.
Yeah.
It's so cool.
I really believe there's like this
ancient connection.
One hundred percent.
Yeah.
And it's like with hunting,
and I'll do a hunting a lot now,
so it's,
I feel like I'm in my element,
but even the first time that I shot
something and I was cutting it up for me
was I felt so comfortable doing it in.
It's like a,
it was like,
I've done this a million times before.
A lot of people say the same thing.
A lot of people say the same thing,
that brian callen in fact said the same
thing.
And he and I went hunting for the first
time and he's like,
it just seems like something we've
always done.
Like there's a memory in our dna and
this is how we've survived.
It was a great thrill.
If you ca,
if you shot a deer,
you know,
10,000,
20,000 years ago and you manage to bring
that back to the village.
Like,
holy shit,
everybody's eating good.
We're going to get by,
we're going to survive.
Or children are going to get nutrition.
Yeah.
Is this deep and meaningful feeling?
And it's not like your shot.
Yeah.
Fucking shot it.
That feeling.
you feel excited,
you feel you like,
yes,
yes.
But it's a different kind of excitement.
It's a,
it's sustenance.
You're going to get nutrients,
you're going to feed your family,
you're gonna and it's all because you
did it the way you did.
Especially bow hunting.
You know,
how difficult it is and you pulled it
off.
There's this thrill of success.
and then there's this deep connection
with your meat.
You know,
when I get an elk,
I kind of love eating that stuff.
so when I get one,
I'm like,
now,
good.
Now I've got meat,
I've got meat from months and I've made
my friends have meat.
I have a fucking.
I have a gang of canadian friends that
are eating elk all the time.
No,
because you know,
I give them sausages and steaks and I
teach them like my friend tom papa,
he,
uh,
I've,
I've taught them how to like cook elk
roasts,
you know,
like he was like,
what do I do?
I'm like,
you got to keep it low and slow.
You want like 275 degrees,
get it to an internal temperature of
135,
somewhere around.
then.
Then you pull it,
sear it on the outside,
let it sit for 10 minutes.
He calls me up a couple of hours later.
Holy shit.
I'm like,
yeah,
that didn't like any of anything else
you're going to eat
anyway.
It's because the hunt starts will.
The hunt probablY starts here for you
because you practice and shoot your
target and then you go through all the
preparation.
You go for the hunt,
you're successful,
you kill the animal.
The hunt doesn't end at killing the
animal that hunt continues to go and
like you ate and the animal on your
plight.
That's the feeling that I get.
You know,
it's like and that that sometimes I'm
like,
it's like why people call me a hunter?
I'm just a human.
This is a human thing to do.
Like go out,
catch your own,
cook it,
eat to survive.
Continued is weird that it's so rare
now.
Yeah.
So how rare is it in Australia?
Like population wise,
auto night?
Fuck all.
There's not a lot of hunters.
I feel like there is,
because I'm in hunting the hunting
community,
so I know a lot of hunters,
but if I go to any given person's house,
that's not.
Most of my friends are hunters as well
now,
but if say I'll go to one of kim's
friends' houses.
there's not one hunt is in that house.
Right.
You know,
and then I'll go to a workplace.
There's no hunters in that workplace.
Like it doesn't come up.
No one's they.
oh,
it's so weird that you what you do,
you know,
it's not,
it's not like that.
Even though it's a part of my family's
heritage,
like I'm like my grandfather,
he would go out trapping.
My uncles had got trapped in.
My dad would do a bit of hunting,
not bow hunting,
and it was different,
you know,
and it was almost like it wasn't even
called hunting back then.
That's what I always think about our
ancestors,
like hunting's,
like almost like a modern word that we
made up because it would have just been
something they do.
It was just normal.
We're hunting,
but everybody does exactly.
When you wash your clothes,
do you call yourself a clothes washer?
Pull this thing in front of you know it
this way.
You're good under your consent.
Weird.
There you go.
clear?
Yeah.
It's like if You wash your clothes,
no fuck no one washes clothes unless
you're a dirty prick.
You know,
everyone does that.
But because people know that I hunt,
people will find me like in like a,
there's a guy like similar and you know,
like he wants to meet me somewhere.
It's like the first thing that comes up
almost like instantly we know each
other.
Do you bow hunt?
Yeah.
Cool.
Where do you go?
I was like,
oh,
you know,
we go to New Mexico every year.
Oh,
cool.
On your fucking business.
Yeah.
That,
yeah.
You and John Dudley had that talk about
public spots and you're like,
because I agree it's not your,
like you don't own it.
Everyone owns public land,
but uh,
I'll take this story back out for john.
But um,
to share that spot is
not the done thing because it's like
everyone should put their own in a sense
to go find a spot to go find a spot and
even if you're happy to share a spot,
because I go to a lot of different
sports and social media ask me to tell
these sports and I never do because that
spot could be someone else's paradise
that they fucking spent 10 years to
find.
Then you give that information out to
the masses is so don't fucking ask,
you know,
that's the thing.
Yeah,
that's the thing,
right?
It's like,
even though these are beautiful and
everybody owns them,
the last thing you want is what's
happening right now in joshua tree,
right in the fucking trash everywhere.
Well that's one thing I really like
about what you do too.
You always make videos of these trash
that you pick up,
you pick,
bring a bag with you and your will.
I started a thing.
So I brought a bunch of gateway with me
and I'm fortunate I've got really good
sponsors and they sent me a bunch of
gear as well.
So I could do the trip over here without
bringing everything and I was walking
around New Mexico actually and I was
looking at all the trash sitting around
and I was like,
fuck it,
I'm going to give away all my equipment
for this trip.
Virtually all my mind hunting gave
backpack bow,
frigging yeti cool.
Whatever,
you know.
And for anyone that tags me In an image
of them picking up trash and I'm not
going to say the description of it now
because it's pretty much ended up giving
the bottle of wine and all my gear and
because these hundreds of doing that
anyway,
but I just thought I'd really drive it
home,
you know,
and thousands and thousands of people
tag me and then collecting rubbish out
in public lands or wherever.
You know,
those people that would post the knee,
they'll picking it up on the beach right
here in la,
you know,
collecting rubbish.
So it was.
Because it's disheartening when you got
that connection to the wall and you see
that,
you know,
like fuck,
that doesn't belong here.
You know,
those loans,
those balloons.
I float away.
They needed the band name fucking things
because they dropped someone walks out,
they let them go out somewhere.
It's usually on the mountain,
you know,
the mountain ends up catching them,
it just doesn't belong there.
I was on the trail yesterday with my dog
and came across as bud light can I just
stopped and just staring at this candle
on the ground.
I'm wanting to find the guy who didn't
shove it down his fucking throat.
What person does.
I always think of that.
I'm like,
who would do that?
It's such a beautiful place and just
being like,
fuck it,
leave it behind.
I say it everywhere like because a lot
of people were like,
I want to apologize on behalf of
America.
I'm like,
fuck,
that's not America.
That's everywhere.
That's people everywhere.
But there's certain places that people
are.
There's different people.
New zealand's one of them.
So New Zealand has like hundreds and
hundreds of public land cabins.
Yeah,
like no fee.
Pretty much nothing but any.
If there is a phase like five bucks and
you can hike in or drive the day's
cabins and you stay in there and they've
gotten mattresses in them,
they got beds,
they got the firewood,
it's left there by the hunters or
outdoors people before you and they are
in pristine condition and there's a
guest book to write.
You're signing the guest book.
If that was in Australia,
if that was in America would be so
fucking vandalize.
IT's not funny,
but new zealand's got a certain type of
people that go into the app,
the bush,
the mountains,
and there's a certain respect that comes
with it and maybe it's from maori
culture or something like that that goes
with it.
Where where that just
doesn't happen.
The person that's here before you cleans
that out,
they sweep it out,
they clean it,
they leave a bit of tin food there or
whatever.
They cut new firewood.
They stack it where it can stay dry.
You know,
things like that and it's and,
and it's something that goes about
signing with me and my people,
how we sort of do.
That's how we are respectful for the
land,
but there's so many people that aren't.
That's okay.
Beautiful thing.
If you find a community like that,
that everybody agrees to respect that
area,
everybody agrees to do that and take
care of things.
I mean,
if you can really come across something
like that,
like where you're talking about New
Zealand is a just a great feeling of
community there.
yeah,
totally.
There's a.
Seems to be a tight hunting community in
America as well.
We're obviously none of that thing would
happen,
but there's so many people that go out
into the outdoors that they belong to,
so I don't want to say that I didn't
belong there,
but the truth is as soon as you later or
something,
you don't fuCking belong there.
Yeah.
Fucking trashy house,
you know?
Yeah.
It's just so unfortunate.
It's unfortunate that people do think
like that.
They think so selfishly.
They just throw a water bottle on the
ground.
They don't care.
No one's going to notice it's out here
in the wilderness.
That's what it is.
It's that so,
so self centered that is like no one or
nothing else matters,
You know,
when so much of that.
So much of that.
And that's what I think is getting
worse.
What's people doing?
A poor job of raising people,
you know,
they're not paying attention.
Yeah.
Raising shitty humans.
I want to fight it like I've constantly
been fighting it and that's why I have a
social,
the social media and stuff to keep
promoting the outdoors and good things
in life and things like that.
But another pod tummies like and I
nearly did it last year.
I just like fuck,
I'll want to go off the grid like,
like really off the grid.
So solar power,
you know,
a couple of thousand acres of and stuff
like that and just cause came pretty
much any age game made it now as well.
Like that's how we've gotten.
So we just want to gain weight and it's
like the next step would be having our
own chickens,
collecting our own eggs,
growing our own vegetables,
like living off the land,
you know?
Do you want to have like a phone out?
Fuck no.
So how long would you lIve out there
for?
Forever.
Forever and ever.
And ever.
How am I going to get in touch with you?
I'll have a phone or your number and I'm
like,
eh.
I just felt like cottonseed oil out,
fucking cut and bills out,
cutting all that shit out.
cut and contact out.
Yeah,
I get that.
Do you still run your company to a
degree?
I've got really good people that run it.
Unfortunately.
My business partner,
she's an indigenous woman in that area.
She just passed away a couple of weeks
ago.
I'm sorry to hear that.
Yeah.
Which is pretty sad.
but um,
long.
Have you known her?
She's uh,
she's my stepmother so long time.
So that was my dad's partner and um,
so the indigenous than like,
they don't really live to a long age.
There's just that they're
sort of,
they're unhealthy in a sense because
they're so not used to our process,
you know,
refined foods and things like that
because,
you know,
indigenous.
How old is dryer?
It's only a couple of hundred years old
and um,
so,
you know,
to get the 60th seems like it's a
freaking miracle for them.
So I'm not sure how old she was,
but she wasn't very old and so
unfortunately she passed away.
She was on a dialysis machine and her
heart was really struggling.
I ended up giving out,
but I'm sorry,
where was I?
Where was I going?
I get it.
Look,
um,
you know,
you just,
you were just talking about,
um,
being off the grid and whether or not
you still run your.
Oh yeah.
So I've got really good people that run
the business for me and um,
yeah,
everything's done by emails and phone
calls and I hardly do any of that
anymore.
I've got my hear from them once a month
if need be,
but I'd even look at selling the.
I'd probably look at selling the
business,
especially off of this has happened
after she's done.
Yeah.
Probably look at selling them the
business,
but it just depends.
A son,
her son is going to take over her
partnership,
you know,
the joint venture with her and stuff
like that,
which will be really good for him and
still allow an income into the family
and things like that.
So,
so we'll just see where it goes.
But yeah,
I was really thinking about going off
the grid and just like always boys
wanted to be like that,
you know,
I just,
I love that lifestyle.
Time seems to go a lot slow when you're
out in the woods facade if you're doing
exactly what you'd want to do.
You know,
I like being in contact with the world
though.
I like both.
I do appreciate off the grid times,
but for me I liked them as like
vacation,
but I like being in contact.
I want to know what's happening with the
world.
I like,
I like being,
I like being aware of cultural change.
I like being also ricardo because of
what I do for a living.
Oh,
for sure.
yeah.
I sort of don't care for it.
Like we don't watch the news at home,
we don't tune into anything like that.
Which you sort of leave out life and
it's like what affects us unless it's
affecting the greater community in a
sense for the worse,
you know,
because the country is run by fucking
clowns.
That's how I feel.
Your country as well.
Yeah.
What's worse?
They talked to these folks are too busy
trying to look good in parliament and
argue with each other to get anything
actually done.
What are the big issues in Australia?
I don't know because I don't tune into
it anymore.
Well you guys have crazy immigration
laws.
Like you don't let anybody go over
there.
Like it's like people who think that the
United States is rough with this whole
wall.
Ah,
yeah.
Australia takes that to a whole new
level.
They ship people to an island.
Christmas island.
It's a fucking nice island.
It.
Yeah.
Well think about what you guys are.
I mean you guys replaced the,
the british prisoners to a way better
place.
Exactly.
I did all the security fencing around
some of the detention
centers.
So you have to pretty much,
you're on that island,
you know,
and then you get shipped to like the
hardest,
most fecund arid part of Australia,
like it's deaf and I did the fencing
around there and then I believe they,
they fsi long than I can ever get
shipped back home where they can go out
to the broader community in Australia,
which they get treated very well
obviously.
So is it just an assessment place like
where they trying to find out your
criminal.
Violent?
Yeah,
I think that's.
And that's the important thing,
you know,
that's why you can't just have open
borders,
you know,
some terrorist comes in,
right?
Some guy that thinks fucking raped,
fond some guy that thinks you know,
crazy shit,
fine,
you know,
assess those people and send them awful.
Yeah.
But if you did that in the most arid
part of America,
people would be so angry because people
start dyIng.
People angry in Australia as well.
And I think that has been desks and
stuff like that.
What are you supposed to do?
It's a tech is,
you know,
it's a very uh,
it's a hard situation.
It's not something that's just like,
no,
just let him fruit.
No,
fuck no.
And it's not like,
just don't let them through that middle
ground again,
you know,
let's them,
let's work it out because I always
think,
what if I was in their shoes,
you know,
I've got kim and the kids or whatever
and now we're in a country that's war
fucking stricken.
I'd be trying to get the fuck out of
there too.
No matter what it took,
you know,
will not,
no matter what it talked about.
But you know,
of course,
yeah.
I mean I always say that about people
that are talking about people sneaking
over this country.
This country is made out of immigrants.
It's an immigrant country.
What do you expect when you go fucking
countries?
Immigrants.
I mean that is,
that's like people in la saying they
don't want anybody moving to la bitch.
Where you from?
We're looking at as dry.
I like where feel fucking white.
You're an input and by the way,
if you are one of the original people
that came here,
I mean one of the original european
settlers,
you probably have fucking slave on your
grandparents were slave owners.
Like if,
if you didn't come over here as a recent
immigrant,
like I'm third generation,
my grandparents came over here from
europe.
If they didn't then if they were here
for 10,
15 generations here,
probably fucking.
Yeah,
exactly.
So I actually,
I never feel a real good connect with
anywhere I go and including my home
Australia because I'm not indigenous,
you know,
it's like weird and I've always looked
at because,
you know,
I don't worry about fucking flags or
borders or anything like that.
I've just always looked at the world the
world has.
Well,
especially as simple as that.
SO much time with the indigenous people
in Australia.
Yeah.
Because at work and,
and not,
you know,
like uh,
no disrespect to any flag.
I love the flag and I love what they
stand for,
but it's not any.
Someone's these on a board is only
something that someone's put on the map,
you know,
it's like of real weird thing like that.
It is a weird thing,
but also you want to protect people from
people that come from 100 percent.
It's less.
The whole world was the same unless
every,
the whole world was on the same level.
You know,
we're not going to do this,
we're not going to do that.
This is illegal.
This is fine.
Unless the whole world was like that,
then borders be easy to cross.
Well,
that's excellent.
We've been talking about this a lot,
that America is essentially like europe,
but everybody speaks the same language,
but you can go to any country like New
Mexico is fucking way different than
miami.
Right?
Miami is way different than la.
La is way different than seattle.
Those are all almost like completely
different place hardly,
but they're all.
You could go to them.
I mean,
ideally that's where it would be.
It would be.
You could travel anywhere where the
opportunity was.
We thought you can get a good job and
you want to better yourself and your
family.
YOu,
you'd have an opportunity.
The fact that currency in life values
are different.
For starters,
he's.
You know why that can't happen?
yeah,
it'd be nice.
Be niCe.
It would be nice if one day the whole
world rises up and you know,
when you look at the western world,
whether it's europe or the United States
and places where things are going really
well or asia,
it would be nice if the whole planet was
like,
if there was no third world,
if everything was fantastic,
if everything was just basically just
like we're talking about here,
hey,
you can live in phoenix or you can live
in billings,
Montana,
or you could live in Massachusetts.
go wherever the fuck you want.
That's what we have here and we have a
really unique thing in this country and
that's why people want to come in.
Yeah,
it's fucking good.
Is pretty dope.
I hear a lot because you always hear the
negative things and I hear a lot of
people were ragging on America and their
own country and stuff like that.
You know,
this is fuck these fucking America is
brilliant.
Strike is brilliant.
These countries,
we're also fucking lucky to be here,
you know,
because you look it up a positive world
and you're like,
fuck,
I can't feed their baby because you know
what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
yeah.
I think africa,
like always frightened my kids and it's
not a free because I love it,
but I always say I'm fucking taking to
africa because a,
have a long ago when I went to africa,
like I was watching little babies in a
village crawl around in like free four
inch,
the dust,
you know,
every second person you met had fucking
war scars on their face,
you know,
and mozambicans,
zimbabweans and uh,
you're driving down,
there's a roadblock.
There's dudes with fucking ak 47.
Is that a duck type together?
There's a guy on the side of the road
with a fucking bazooka or rocket
launcher or you don't know if they
friend or foe,
you know?
And this is just not a normal everyday
life going for africa.
There's a tourist bus on the side of the
road.
It's fucking burn out and it's just
bullet hole sprite for a line of the
windows,
you know?
And shit like that.
And it's like fuck,
this isn't Australia,
this isn't America,
this is different.
And,
and sometimes in my kids they're
grateful but they are on a different
tune than me and I'm just like fuck,
they need a trip to africa and I can
see,
not that I'm trying to expose someone
else's life so my kids realize like,
but just so they can feel,
you know,
like you've got a good,
you've got a good life,
you're like appreciate.
It can be a lot harder.
It's hard to appreciate,
right.
It's like we were talking about going
into the bush and if you go into the
bush for seven days then you come out,
you appreciate hot water.
He appreciates sunshine if you'd been
out in the rain.
But it's hard for people to appreciate
it without actually experiencing it
because you can only conceptualize it so
much in your head unless you're actually
there.
It's,
it doesn't do it,
does it.
And that's virtually reality is never
going to touch on that ab,
huh?
No,
no.
It's going to turn us into this some
weird spongy looking fucking soft jelly
bag.
Exactly,
yeah,
I'm worried.
I'm really worried about the future,
but I guess that's just what happens.
I mean,
cause it seems like,
look,
we'll mild nana and pa would have been
saying the same thing about our
generation now.
Well we are soft as fuck in comparison
to chimps are ancient.
Ancient ancestors were something like
chimps and they're probably looking at
us now.
It'd be like,
look at these pussies with their shoes.
They need houses.
You can't even sleep at a tree fucking
dummies.
You know what I mean?
Like they totally.
But we don't want to live like that
either.
It'll,
maybe the matrix will be so beautiful.
But as adam greentree running around
with a fucking gun,
that doesn't work,
stick it in the facebook.
That's fucking funny.
I,
um,
if I'm hunting and it's raining,
I always what gets me out there and
continues me to hunting their guy and
he's on like,
it's fucking water.
Like I have a shower every night when
I'm at home,
I get the dry off afterwards.
But I'm like,
have you ever seen animals in the rain?
Like an animal will be like fading and
it sunshine just fading and it will stop
pissing down raining.
It just keeps feeding.
It doesn't even fuCking like,
well,
it doesn't just deal.
it's just fucking life.
You know,
it's life.
And I always think I'm just an animal.
Like what's the difference?
I'll get hypothermia and die.
Well gortex,
she gets some audio record,
textbook,
you're fine.
then it's like,
but even if you don't,
it's like fuck,
whatever.
You just,
it's just water.
The technology today,
like what they figured out for outdoor
gear.
So good.
You were,
you know,
merino wool,
which even when it gets wet,
keeps your body warmth in this.
The water protection.
This gear so good.
There's so many different companies that
make outstanding stuff now.
You can be fine in the rain.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And yeah,
I just think that we just keep it and
sorry,
moved.
Like as soon as it rains,
like everyone runs to the car runs here.
So here they don't even know how to
drive.
Yeah.
Oh fuck.
Oh my god.
A little bit of drizzle it,
but it'S like,
ah.
And the accidents everywhere.
People don't,
don't realize it gets slippery.
You dumb fucks.
Change of driving.
Fucking ali has been.
It's so goofy.
It's nearly upsetting because I'm like,
people have to do this everyday to go to
work.
Oh,
traffic.
Some people's lives.
I'm like,
what the why the fuck would you do that?
Like people
they fucking caught up in the whole
system.
If you drive out to like a,
like you go up the five and head towards
palm dale or bakersfield or any place
out there and you see traffic at like
6:00 in the morning bumper to bumper.
all people making it to la so they drive
an hour all the way out to palmdale
hour,
15 hour 20 because the rent is cheaper
and then they make their way or a home
that their law,
their life everyday.
Three hours plus of driving in the car,
orange county,
the people that live in orange county,
that place is fucking dense.
Dense.
It's beautiful out there.
It's great.
Great place to live,
but god damn.
If you have to go anywhere,
like if you have to drive to hollywood
everyday,
good fucking luck keeping your sanity
that there's probably a car right now
listening to us.
Is this five reopens in the grapevine
after.
What is it?
Snow.
Last month when it first snowed,
like this is what you're saying,
like palmdale area.
This is,
it was snowing in palmdale.
Just shut everything down.
I got stuck.
That's the thing.
If someone's got a goal in there,
I'm in towards that and doing the job to
get that goal than fucking good on them.
But other than that,
if you're doing thiS for a fucking dead
end job vehicles just sitting on the
highway covered in snow.
Yeah.
That's where you want a four wheel drive
truck with some good fucking knobby
tires.
No,
that's when you ring up and sound not
coming.
Yeah.
That too.
I feel sorry.
Sorry for anyone that's caught out with
that.
So rare.
This is out there too.
No one knows what the fuck to do when it
snows.
I grew up in Boston and in the snow.
Uh,
I had to drive every day in the snow
because I delivered newspapers.
that was my job from time I was like 17
till I was 22 ish,
somewhere around there.
Maybe the last time I stopped 22,
23.
I got up every fucking morning.
So it taught me two things.
One,
it taught me discipline because I had to
be up at 5:00 in the morning no matter
what,
even earlier on sundaY because it was a
big fix.
Sunday papers,
you have to make multiple trips.
I Even had a van that I bought a cargo
van just to deliver newspapers in some
shitty cargo van.
I forgot to change the oil and
brought it to the guy and I go what's
wrong?
And he's like,
you didn't have any oil.
And I'm like,
fuck,
I'm not good with cars.
But I drove in the snow every day,
man.
So if I'm in the snow today,
I'm like,
I feel my ass and kick out.
whoa,
hey,
I know what to do here.
You don't panic.
I don't slam on the brakes.
Like I drove a lot in snow.
Did you remember having like a set goal
at that Point doing that job?
No,
I just wanted to not work and nobody
could tell them what to do when I was in
my car because I like.
the thing about it is I had a job,
this was my task.
I had hundreds of houses that I
delivered newspapers too,
but I didn't have anybody with me while
I was doing it.
So while doing it,
nobody's telling me what to do and
nobody's yelling at me.
I'd listened to the radio,
listen to talk radio and just listen to
music,
think about jokes and shit and just
throw newspapers out the window.
It was nice.
It is nice to not have someone that.
It was better for me.
I would waY rather work seven days a
week and it was only a few days,
a few hours a day.
So even though it was everY single day,
it was only like three hours a day,
you know,
I was done by eight and I'd go back to
sleep.
Yeah,
you've goT the biggest fucking podcast.
it's crazy.
I saw I've being self employed since I
was 21.
Yeah.
And I had a big media company reached
out to me not so long ago and the
biggest thing that turned me off because
the pricing and everything was right was
unlike a fucking contact orders or what
they want you to take orders,
a podcast types.
Yeah.
Pretty much.
I mean a lot of my content and
unfortunately a part of that would have
been changing some of the companies that
I'm with and like I'm friends with the
companies with those companies because
they're what I want to be like hunting
companies.
Yeah.
And uh,
but the thought of happened to be on
someone else's timeline.
Then like I was like,
I fucking don't want to do that.
I can,
like right now I'm just doing me and
whatever happens happens.
And it's like your situation,
you know?
Yeah.
If I even had a guy that I had to check
in with once a month and say,
so,
uh,
everything looks good.
We got an upward trend here.
I'd be like,
I would fucking phone call again.
Yeah.
And I'm such a spur of the moment guy
this hunt come up on going there but
want to do this with the kids or kid the
family onto calendar and doing it.
I really liked that.
So relaxing dude to be like that and
that's why I built the business that
I've got to where it is as well where I
don't have to be at work continually.
How often are you putting out your
podcast?
RIght now?
I've put a hold on it since this trip
because it's just been so.
Even though this trip would have been
epic to do it on,
I guess I just haven't done it because
everything's like so fast forward.
It's insane.
Plus you have the kids with you that's
hours a day that you just don't know
exactly yet,
but as soon as I get back home,
which is like a middle of february after
the western expo,
then I'm going to start pumping it
again.
I love doing.
I love doing that.
When does that start?
RIght?
I think it's like 15th 16th.
17th of february movie.
Really?
You should get along.
I've been there before the February 14th
to the 17th western expo in salt lake
city,
Utah,
but daddy's not pre.
On the 14th is valentine's day.
You got to pick your battles,
pick your battles,
pick your battles.
You got to know what to do.
Like I make sure that I take plenty of
family vacations around hunting trips.
Yeah,
totally.
So we just went over to the big island,
didn't you know,
we went to maui.
Oh,
we did that for new years.
Yeah.
I decided to stop working on new years.
Yeah,
because right now I can't really work
anyway,
like legitimately for a couple months
because I don't have enough material
because I just did a netflix special and
I want to make sure I don't want anybody
coming to see me and I'm half ass.
So if I'm doiNg sets around la,
like right now I could rock it for 20
minutes or half hour.
That's easy.
I mean that's not easy,
but it's doable.
It's legit.
I don't feel like I'm a fraud.
Like if I do a half hour show,
that's a real half hour show,
but it's not a real.
Our show is a big deal because our show,
like in a theater or an arena,
I really need an hour and 20 [inaudible]
I know you gotta make sure everything's
good.
It's just there's a giant
responsibility.
You don't want to leave anybody.
People get babysitters and they take
time out of the day.
I got to be prepared so I work hard at
it.
So I was thinking about new years and
when it came they were trying to set up
new year's gigs for me and I'm like,
not only am I not ready,
I don't think I want to do it because it
seems like such a big event.
Totally.
New year's is
snow.
Why can't believe it?
We're celebrating.
It's like vegas on crack,
you know?
It's like the whole thing has just
ramped up so far.
Past normal
show show,
I would say,
well we're out in the desert.
We should make human.
The kIds on new year's and to everything
else.
Yes.
Fucking tons like normal.
But that the human rights,
it's like because it's written on a
calendar,
it's like these big deal,
you know,
and it is cool,
but fuck,
it seems like such a good time just to
chill with me.
Yeah,
It was a good time to chill.
Yeah.
We went to the,
you know,
we were staying at a resort in maui and
was beautiful and the food was great and
it was picked up.
Beach was great.
Just chill.
I need more of that in my life.
I need more chill time,
just everything.
I'm just doing so many different things.
I have to balance it out with nothing.
Sometimes
there is because when I'm go,
go,
go.
Sometimes I'm just like,
fuck,
I just want to sit on the couch and I
feel lazy as fuck when I do it because
I'm so used to going.
But thAt sitting on the couch and
watching a movie and just chill and it's
like you recharged.
Holy shit.
Damn you recharge.
It totally isn't a makes you hungry to
go,
go again.
You know,
sometimes I need that.
I need that for.
That took me awhile to figure that out
with stand up to.
so like sometimes I need to take little
breaks just to recharge my imagination,
recharged my enthusiasm for it.
There's a balance in life.
Like you can't work out five hours a day
every day you break your body.
Totally need breaks and I think you need
breaks with your imagination.
You need breaks with enthusiasm,
with everything.
Yeah.
let them on reset.
So,
so what are you doing while you were in
la?
Like how long are you going to be here?
Uh,
so we
did disney with the kids and just
chilled out.
We're leaving tomorrow hidden back to
Utah,
salt lake city and do up there.
Pretty much getting organized to go back
home.
So I'm going to drop the winnebago
trailer.
I'm going to drop off there and
declutter.
Yeah.
I'm going to go visit hoyt.
I'm going to send out a bunch of this
shit that I said I'd give away and stuff
like that.
Then we're going back to Utah.
Utah's been our base pretty much.
Some friends are up,
Utah going to go back to Utah and pack
up a bunch of stuff and then I'll get a
bison hunt that I'm going to do.
That's the last hunt while I'm in
America.
And then down to the western expo,
we've got a,
like a white screen and one of the
movies that I did there,
I did a movie over in New Zealand and
uh,
the boys from a bow hunt down under in
Australia,
filmed it for me and they did a fucking
awesome job.
well,
the one you guys did with cam,
the under armour one was fantastic.
It was really good.
That was good.
They did a great job with.
They're fun
do than what the fucking movie is
because you know,
they want to cut it,
cut it down to 20 minutes.
I made that one pretty long where it was
20 something minutes.
But um,
because main cam I'd like two weeks
together.
Fucking running around going was
awesome.
And there's so much that they can't show
in that 20 minutes.
Of course,
you know,
and like some really cool shit.
I'm hoping to get cameron out again this
year.
I've got those two buffalo hunts lined
up and you need to come out to,
which would be fun
and wholesome.
You're already fucking criteo.
What else can I do?
I had it all fucking planned.
This whole.
The city of this whole trip.
I bet.
No,
no.
What I've been doing in America,
I've been collecting fucking spiders and
snakes and shit like that and I was
gonna let them all fucking go in the
studio,
dude.
I was going to let them all go in the
studio.
I'm like,
fuck.
He will never have me on again if I knew
that,
but I was going to bring one in here
with me to just show me just fucking
now.
I was just going to let it out halfway
through them and see if you could carry
on.
I had an old fucking lined up and then I
got changed because I had to go to
Arizona.
I didn't get to go back to Idaho.
We're all fucking creepy.
let them all go.
Did you go to Idaho?
It all this trump hates.
It was fucking amazing.
That's Idaho.
Might be like the undiscovered gem,
like
in this country,
there's fucking no one there to.
Boise is fantastic.
I fucking love that city.
I had a great time there man.
It's beautiful in the mountains out
there.
So good is,
it's
a pretty place.
So our friends a bicycling,
so every time we fly in every year when
we fly and I usually fly in the Idaho
first right up high near spokane,
like near Washington.
And then we ended up driving from there
to southern Colorado,
southern Colorado,
New Mexico,
New Mexico back to southern Colorado.
[inaudible] came out of promo and tags
dealing.
She ended up tagging a promo and then
this is how my sheet I'll fucking done
on this trip.
I can't,
I had to get in the fucking write it
down because I'm like,
where have we been?
It's been hectic and um,
I think I'll be in Idaho like four or
five times in this trip,
like back and forth,
back and forth.
Did you ever go to quarter lane?
Yep.
Yeah.
I haven't had my friends in the accord
line.
It's beautiful.
It's so clear.
You could see like a hundred feet down
the bottom.
It's a fucking nice spot.
I've got to bring up this message and
read it out.
It's.
Yeah,
it's been crazy.
so we ended up.
We flew in the Idaho and we went to
southern Colorado and we went to New
Mexico back to southern Colorado,
backup the Idaho,
and then I ended up flying out.
Now we ended up driving the eastern
Oregon,
the hump bull elk.
Then I ended up flying out to Arizona to
hunt elk as well on the navajo
reservation,
which was really cool.
Then we.
Then I flew to bc hunted moose,
then I flew back,
then we went to Kentucky.
I drive all the way to Kentucky with the
kids,
which took like four or five days.
I was fucking insane.
We took it out on sort of checking it
out,
you know,
where there's nothIng.
There's absolutely nothing.
Nebraska dude hall leaf.
We drove for hours and hours for
Nebraska and like saying nothing but
luck cornfield or something like that.
sorry,
anyone from Nebraska,
but Nebraska was born in Nebraska right
now.
Oh my gosh.
I'm sure there's some pretty places.
I don't think so.
They know about it.
Yeah,
that's right.
it wasn't.
That was it.
oh,
Kansas was dorothy wizard of oz.
We went to Texas.
We drove down to Texas.
How long have you guys been here?
Four plus months.
Your kids are holding up remarkably
well.
Oh,
they are awesome.
Having a good old time.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
At least in front of you.
There's been some good arguments on the
way,
but they have pretty good.
I'm like,
fuck.
They lIke eva locked in a trailer or
locked in the car or were in like an
airbnb or something like that and they
were all gathered together and,
and it's not until you're around other
people's kids that you realize how good
your own kids are like that because I'm
always like,
you know,
and then they give a random occasion
like fuck our kids is science,
you know,
santa claus.
But yeah.
Then we went from Texas to Utah,
hung at Utah for a wall.
Then I drove back to Colorado,
come back to Utah again.
Well,
what's ironic is that you as an
australian and your family as
australians are getting to see more of
americans,
most americans ever do like fucking get
out there and do it.
Get out there And get out there and do
it.
A beautiful place we live in.
I think some people don't have the means
to.
Yeah,
and that's why people are driving for
this fuck traffic every day to try and
make the means to do that,
you know?
Yep.
Yeah.
But it's a grind out there fuckers.
It's a grind.
Yeah.
The traffic does my fucking head in
concrete does my head in mass paper do
my head in like I'm walking around
disney like a duck.
But isn't it fun to do like every now
and again to go to New York city every
now and again?
Just go jesus fucking people you been.
Have you been in New York?
It's crazy.
That's the trippiest trip and all of
this fucking wild as country.
I think the reason why hunters get so
much flack from a lot of people is
because I asked in that they don't know
the upper end of things.
They don't know the wilderness side of
things because they fucking jammed in
there.
I always think like that's why I love
promoting it as well.
So much like people don't even know
about this.
They don't even know exists.
They don't even know this is something
you can do.
They don't know the rewards from it,
so they feel morally detached from the
food that they're reading.
like they don't feel like an obligation
to their food.
They don't feel like they don't need me.
It's just a steak.
There's no,
there's no connection.
And because of that they don't feel like
they did anything wrong.
No,
that's wrong.
Whereas if you shoot a font and you know
and you're like,
oh,
he shot a baby,
what do you think?
Your veal is stupid.
What do you think?
Laminate had full.
Everything was out of the rack of lamb.
Yeah,
you ordered a baby.
That's a baby.
Lamb is a baby sheep.
Fuck.
But most people,
it's weird.
I don't.
So I don't hate on it because I
understand it like that.
The population of the world demands,
but if someone hates on me for it,
then you've got a point of out.
I'm sTill not heightened on it.
I'm just pointing it out.
Or you're doing the same thing,
but someone else is doing it for you.
It's out of ignorance for sure.
Yeah,
and even if you're a vegan or
vegetarian,
you know,
that's still kills animals.
Like have a look at the cleared land to
be a vague and they need to clean land,
you know,
so it's like that's that whole middle
ground again.
Yeah.
Unless your farm yourself.
If everyone went vegan,
we'd fucking have to clear massive
amounts of land,
kill massive amounts of animals and
everything like that.
Do you know what I mean?
Went hunting is then fuck them.
Would slaughter the fuck out.
It's so much wildlife.
It's not funny.
On top of that,
you wouldn't be able to just let those
animals loose.
Let all the cows,
louis,
you slamming into fucking cars on the
street.
Just devastating like know ground that
can't be trampled on like that.
But it's that middle ground.
Yeah.
Some vegans and vegetarians a good,
you know,
some hunters and not a good.
And then there's that middle ground
which is all the normal cunts,
you know,
that just understand like I've got a
mate,
it's not actually damaging,
you know,
I can eat some vegetables that's not
damaging.
It's just everything in its place.
Yeah,
no,
that's what your perspective is very
healthy.
That it's good to have these extreme
animal rights activist because it
balances everything out.
We need balance.
I agree.
Just don't fucking mouth off at me about
it.
It
sounds so much better with an australian
accent because really so normal in
Australia started.
Even when your wife says that,
it's just like it's normal.
Normal.
So our friend sam soho,
which uh,
he put up a post and it was about some
politician.
Yeah,
there you go.
Beautiful.
And was wearing a shirt earlier.
he makes an awesome shirt.
yeah.
I was sweaTing it and otherwise I'd wear
it here.
Public land.
Diana.
That's it by the sam.
Hell yeah.
Oh boy.
So he put this post up and it's about
this politician that,
you know,
he,
he goes,
you know,
it's a pretty decent fucking riding that
he's done up about,
you know,
how the guy's not doing his job and
stuff like that and they're going to
take these public what land away from us
or close it and I'm in the comments on
like,
so basically what you're saying is these
account,
we can get there a little quicker.
He's doing,
he's not doing his job and fuck some
people took offense to it,
but sam explained to him.
He's like,
he's an australian,
it's a prison colony here.
It's like,
oh,
you know,
it's like saying I'm not even going to
say it.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
So it's a bad word.
It's a bad word.
Does not like over there.
It's like a gentle fucker.
Hey
jamie.
Jamie walked in here.
I go,
hey fucker.
If he said that to me,
I'd be like,
hey,
what's up is normal.
There's four things you can't do.
You can't say anything bad about what
talent hunting.
Can't say anything bad about fucking
jesus.
You can't say the word can't.
And I can't remember what the fourth one
wasn't something the american flag like
fucking dog go.
They leave the flag alone.
Leave the fucking flag is beautiful.
That motherfucker out lyrics on dude.
We just did three hours again.
Wow.
Just flew by wild,
crazy coffee.
It's coffee.
This rooms rooms and god.
Damn time.
Fuck.
I wanted kanye to be in yet at the same
time so we can gang up and even told him
in the bowhunting silicon right here.
Killer mike's coming out of the podcast
soon.
He said that,
uh,
he wants to go elk hunting with me,
but his wife won't let them hunt with
white people.
So I told her that one point six percent
african.
So thanks for having me on the show.
It's always,
always a good time to see you,
my friend.
And we got to schedule another one night
trip in northern territory or
stay at the four seasons.
I love you buddy.